[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys it's wednesday yeah time
for the main show yeah i've been
drinking part of the day
so i've already kind of pre-gamed
admission
[Laughter]
i'm still good though this is going to
be a [ __ ] great show jenny and i have
been talking about it before this show
started this show is going to be about
was the phantom of the opera based on
some true [ __ ]
yeah i kind of think it was but we're
going to get into it because i put her
on it
and she's gonna do a deep dive and do
some research
but i read the book
and too much [ __ ] sounded like something
that would have happened
we're gonna get into it though yeah
let's see who's here i've actually
really been looking forward to doing the
show yes i love
uh i really like the book and i really
like all the classic horror adaptations
of it and i knew that some of it was
kind of partially based on real [ __ ] but
until i started doing kind of like a lot
of deep dive into it i didn't realize
all of the connections so i've spent
like the last couple days like going
down all these rabbit holes i got all
right her high iq
i was just going through it by [ __ ]
gut instinct and i was going like i
think this really happened
and gaston laro
on his deathbed said no this did happen
i researched it and
evidently he did kind of say that yeah
well you know i dressed it up i made a
story into it but he believed that
something like this really happened
based upon the descriptions of the
witnesses that he talked to and it was
something that happened about 20 years
before he wrote the book about it
and
the more i looked the more i thought
about what he's talking about he's
talking about somebody like h.h holmes
and he's talking about
and this guy
had a disease that is based in reality
and i'm going like
i think this happened
or something like what he's saying it
did happen
but we're going to see we're going to
see what jenny dug up
what you said when we were talking about
hh homes because you were saying about
how the phantom of the opera had
particularly toward the end of the book
which i will i you know if you guys like
i will do a plot synopsis if you want me
to because i know that some people have
just seen maybe the andrew lloyd webber
musical or something like that maybe
some people know like the kind of
broad outline of the plot but don't know
like what the book the book is it's very
different the book
yeah so there have been a lot of
adaptations of it but you know we both
uh listen to the audiobook actually yeah
and i had read the book before but it
was a long time ago and so i kind of
i'll do like a plot synopsis of the book
and hopefully that'll uh be yeah there
isn't this big rope okay
founder of the opera was not a romance
gaston larose book was not a romance i
mean not really the [ __ ] serial
killer he's talking about yeah
i mean he was but he was more like a
stalker
like he was trying to gain love but
there's no way he was a bad dude even
before this [ __ ] happened yeah and a lot
of it had to do with the issues his
issues figure it out thank you very much
zach what's that yeah two of my favorite
people oh thank you thank you very much
you're one of our favorite people too
yeah this has been one of the most
stressful weeks of my life so glad to
see y'all wow i'm sorry about that zach
you need a blow job
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] there well
although tom's been tom's been at the at
i posted it all day
yeah
i posted uh when did you leave one 1 30
to something right no around that i
think it was about 1 30. i posted a
video met a met up with a biker girl
named meg and meg i made a video with
her of her showing off her sportster you
guys will [ __ ] like it she's good she
was a cool girl and she turned out she
was a dj
so i was going to make an introduction
with [ __ ] big tom from mannequins oh
hey yeah
because she's like i don't need to
[ __ ] do a biker night somewhere and i
said mannequins in the
and the [ __ ] warlocks and she's oh
yeah yeah i know yeah yeah big time
would be down for that yeah yeah yeah so
we'll see that actually might be kind of
fun yeah i wouldn't mind going yeah
and she's got a good taste in music just
light on the lettered skinner yeah
that's all i'm saying no no no she was
doing good she did some really good cz
top and motorhead type stuff yeah he had
rather like i'm more of the motorhead
like kind of thing yeah
but uh yeah so
so yeah so tom's already been drinking
but yeah you know he said before he went
he was like well i'm gonna try not to
drink too much because you know this is
this was his idea for a show and he's
like excited about it yeah he's like i
don't want to be too incoherent like not
being able to finish this yeah but yeah
so uh so i'll get into like a plot
synopsis and stuff and then i kind of
wanted to do
like
a lot of the stuff that you know uh
people say is based on real stuff
because i will say
a lot of stuff in phantom of the opera
was based on real [ __ ] that happened
um that's all i'm going to say right now
yeah get into it but we'll get into it
later on there's a great site i don't
know if the person that did it is still
maintaining it but i think it's called
phantomstheater.com if i'm not mistaken
and the person that put that site up
was like the world's most obsessed
person with like phantom of the opera
the original novel all the adaptations
everything you sent him a link to this
show and uh and yeah well like i said i
don't know if i didn't like uh i don't
know if the site's maintained anymore i
don't think it is um but
it's like pages and pages and pages and
that person actually had a lot of um
original articles about stuff that
happened at the opera house like back in
the day like the in the original french
and had like the translations and stuff
like that uh pictures of people from the
time that it's like could this have been
you know the the person that they were
talking about with the phantom like
somebody with a black cloak on stuff
like that so i kind of like it was too
much to go into like in a couple of days
but i did like read a bunch of the stuff
that was on there so
we'll get into that as well but that's
like a really good uh site that's a
really good resource if you're super
into it but like i said the more i
looked into it like the more you know
how i get like if i'm like super really
in interested in something
then i'll just be like following links
all over the place and soon there'll be
like 30 tabs open and i'm just kind of
like
just going down little rabbit holes
about [ __ ] because it's like it's
[ __ ] fascinating so i found this like
really really fascinating i didn't know
there was like all this
all this lore like surrounding all this
[ __ ] yeah
some people might say well look phantom
of the opera and then they think of the
[ __ ] the that old original movie it
was like a long chain
and you they see that makeup and they go
oh something like that couldn't exist
yeah hell yeah it could have
yes it could have we're gonna get into
that
there's a lot of stuff that was very
plausible in that story
there are diseases that back in those
days that could have done that to a
dude's face
and there were geniuses that ended up
being serial killers there
what the story is describing
there's a dude with a disease
that will get into that okay
who was an intelligent [ __ ] dude who
did something kind of like what h.h
holmes did
and the book and the story
do confirm do correspond
to geography and underground lakes and
[ __ ] and oh yeah
islands
and
the creator gaston loro swore on his
[ __ ] death bed that yeah
i investigated it and it was true this
is what happened
and
he wrote the book in 1909 or 1906 i
don't remember 1909 it was well it was
serialized in uh the newspaper at first
and then like they put it out as a book
like in 1910 but it started out in 1909
like in chapters like there'd be like a
chapter each year and he's dead or each
week he's writing about something that
happened at least 20 years before that
and he went to france to find witnesses
to do the investigation
and
he says that he got evidence based on
witnesses that were there
and all based upon that
evidence
he wrote the book phantom of the opera
it can't it may be one of the first
[ __ ] novels about a real serial
killer
although whatever maybe i was gonna say
like i think and i got like distracted
and like off track because i started
talking about something else yeah but
remember the other day like when you
brought up the topic for this and you
said something about how um you know
particularly toward the end of the novel
where
you know there's basically like a
torture chamber type situation that he
has going on down there and you said
we're like oh it's like h.m murder
castle um
and we couldn't remember like offhand
like when that was but it's very very
possible maybe even probable that gaston
larue
knew about hh homes because hh homes
okay was executed in 1896. okay
and the [ __ ] of like the [ __ ] about the
murder castle even though some of that's
like exaggerated yeah that was like big
news all over the u.s all over europe
okay and gaston larue like was
started out as a newspaper reporter so
he would have known so he probably would
have heard about that okay so he
probably would have so we'll we're gonna
see we're gonna see yeah um
but yeah when i was reading that i was
like this is plausible i was reading i
was reading this and maybe i don't know
2003 2004 yeah and it just [ __ ] was
hitting me like he's talking about a
serial killer
i mean he essentially is i mean that's
what the dude is right and there wasn't
any profiling in in the time of gaston
laro there was no term serial killer
they didn't actually use the term serial
killer until the 1970s yeah really yeah
even though obviously there'd been
serial killers before that like jack the
ripper that was you know 1888. and from
what i remember of the of gaston's story
i was like man this is all fallen in
line with the fbi profiling
[ __ ] data that i read you know i was
like this is a serial killer is
everybody's talking about yeah
uh
zach sent us another super chat thank
you very much again what do you say
something interesting i've seen is that
all the movie versions of phantom of the
opera have been notable or gotten awards
for their cinematography yeah isn't that
interesting yeah they're better [ __ ]
on weird [ __ ] movie adaptations let
me nip this [ __ ] in the bud people
nip it in the bud andy the phantom
was not a romantic
figure
okay
that's a that's a more recent this
iteration thing well the same kind of
thing happened with dracula i mean
you know he was kind of a monster in the
novel but then he sort of got
romanticized through the movies
in in gaston's original
book he's talking about a stalker
torturer and a serial murderer that's
what he's talking about
what are you doing folks can't you see
i'm doing a show yeah what the hell
she's like don't yell at me she turned
around she was like what what
no she has she has a little toy that you
put treats in it you knock it around and
little treats come out of its butt or
whatever yeah she's got one of those and
she's like knocking it around that's
what that noise is don't be alarmed um
slash fred says uh robert englund once
played the role yes that's right he did
uh the variation that he played was
actually a lot more horror based and a
lot more gruesome like the mask that he
wore was like made of stitched together
skin from like his victims and stuff
which
is crazy like that's not anything like
the novel but in a way it's kind of
closer to like making him a more
romantic like i said the novel does have
a gothic
romance quote-unquote kind of thing
because
you know because the phantom is in love
with
christine
but
it's a it's not a it's not real love
it's like a creepy stalkery possessy
kind of yeah [ __ ] it's like a horror
story yeah it's not a romance
talking about a twisted man
who had a background
in torture
professional torture according to the
book
um a guy who was uh he was twisted from
birth
and uh
made a fortune on being an interrogator
and a torturer and an assassin and an
assassin yeah did he do anything about
poisons and [ __ ] all this strangling
yeah that was that was his uh forte yeah
he's not a random [ __ ] he shows
up rich
after doing all this working for a
sultan
according to the book
and uh he's never had
love with a woman because because of
what a monster he is physically
although his personality probably
doesn't help yeah
well he was twisted he was twisted by
his by fate
it's he was a bad luck figure
yeah
but so he's sympathetic on that score
but he's all serial killers are bad luck
figures eileen warnos was a bad luck
figure i mean she was sucking dick by 12
for cigarettes
but she was still a murderer i mean that
should not happen in any just words
that's as an excuse not the world we
live in you know what i mean she was
built from day one
to be a loser and a murderer
sad
yeah but true well like i said some
people don't have any chance yeah right
and he was kind of like that as soon as
they're born they're like kind of [ __ ]
right although i would say that eric and
that's what that was the phantom's real
name according to the book in the
description of him eric was a genius in
many ways yeah in the book he was a
musical genius yeah
and an architectural and an
architectural genius uh and he was also
really good at like uh stage magic yeah
and uh ventriloquy all this like circus
type arts yeah because that's how we
grew up we'll get into that had he been
born in the modern era in an era of
scientific understanding he would have
been a lot better off but that was not
the era that he was born and he was born
in the victorian era
where
yeah you watch the elephant man you see
how that worked out your physical
appearance was
really dictated how you how your life
would go
because ugliness was equated to
immorality in a lot of ways and that's
just evil yeah and i mean like it still
is a little bit but not to the extent
that it was back then if you were born
[ __ ] up looking nobody said oh my god
that's so unfortunate we should be like
super nice to that no you still rocks at
you yeah everybody said there must be
something wrong with like morally wrong
with that person to have come out
looking like that yeah
you know it was a very unfortunate time
which is that's [ __ ] up because you
were dealing with that you were you were
dealing with very simple people
there wasn't a big difference between
the victorian era and the classical
roman era
they were very similar
yeah um
hey there's a weird one person let's
throw they're bad yeah
well it's kind of a psychological you
could go into [ __ ]
psychoanalysis you can go say well
i
don't want that to be me so therefore
i'm going to reject it
oh yeah i definitely think that's a big
part it has a lot to do with it that's a
big part of it but one and honestly i
think that's kind of behind
a lot of that sort of uh
that sort of mindset anyway yeah because
if you just think that person that was
just like an accident of birth which it
is it's like a genetic accident then it
could happen to anybody right you don't
want to hear that you could have a baby
that looked like that yeah and then
where would you be you don't want to
hear that you want to hear that there's
a reason for it right right because if
anybody could happen it could happen to
you then [ __ ]
now that make that that frightens me
yeah so therefore i'm going to reject
that and say no there has to be there
was a reason right
like that person was a bad person or
that person's mother was a bad person i
mean whatever people want to live in a
world where there's um order
even though order doesn't exist when it
comes to [ __ ] like that that's what i
mean sometimes there's just like random
[ __ ] yeah and
that's why honestly like i said
man just be [ __ ] nice to people no
matter what they look like be
understanding and just be understanding
of people at least because you don't
know you don't know what [ __ ] they
[ __ ] dealt with you know what i mean
and they and a lot of times they can't
help some of the [ __ ] that you know
especially what they look like
disfigurements some disfigurements are
because of accidents
uh some of them are having to do with
[ __ ] your behavioral [ __ ] profile
like i could get disfigured because i
ride bikes and do weird [ __ ] she could
happen on a motorcycle yeah your face
could get all [ __ ] up you get all
[ __ ] up and then you could wear
phantom of the opera mask in the cape
and be all like
i go to war and i got burned up by
[ __ ] white phosphorus you know what i
mean yeah got your legs shot off right
that's one thing uh but there is a
[ __ ]
that makes sense but this whole genetic
thing or this whole accidental thing
some people don't want to hear that they
want to reject that
i understand why like i said everybody i
kind of feel because that puts everybody
at risk what's it called the just world
hypothesis
world you know where you think that well
because and you see it in a lot of ways
oh well that person is poor so they must
have done something to deserve being
poor in like their lives like back in
the day or like oh well if they're poor
they must like spend all their money on
drugs or something like that they always
have so there's always this kind of like
moralized you know instead of just
saying oh well maybe they grew up poor
and they you know never really got out
of that or they couldn't afford to go to
college or they had bad nutrition or
something i never learned how to come
out right there's always kind of like
other factors
that are at play there has to be losers
in life anyway think about it i mean
there's always going to be there's
always going to be no and then and then
if everybody's winning but some of them
are not winning as much then they become
the losers so it all becomes a [ __ ]
thing about scale
poverty of today
has nothing to do with poverty of the
middle ages it's all relative it's all
relative
poor people of today
have [ __ ] floors in their houses
and not just dirt yeah and [ __ ] air
conditioning i mean unless they're
homeless unless they're really homeless
no they don't have that they just have a
refrigerator box but it's just
there has been progress no matter what
you say
there has been a program like probably
not as much as some of us would like
think about it this way think about it
this way but it's better than not
you can go to the hood
and find a dude who's [ __ ] slinging
crack and he's [ __ ]
big risk factor dude okay the way his
life but he has a phone
that can do things that the richest
mother [ __ ] in the world could not
have done in other words [ __ ] oh
what's his name
again
howard hughes could not have done what
that dude could do with his phone
well i mean if you went back just 100
years right with a smartphone they would
think that [ __ ] was magic magic right
yeah and most people can afford i'm like
like i said homeless people obviously
can't afford one but
most people
even if you're pretty broke can afford
some
iteration of that right
to reiterate what i say one of the
richest [ __ ] who have ever
existed in in terms of his time was
howard hughes
you know
one of the great one of the things that
separated him the most from poor people
is that that [ __ ] had air conditioning
[Laughter]
had hair conditioning he also peed in
hairs and dinner but yeah right but he
had air conditioning and air
conditioning was [ __ ] expensive as
[ __ ] nowadays anybody can buy a [ __ ]
hundred dollar air conditioner and set
that [ __ ] in his [ __ ] honestly if i
have to live in florida i would rather
[ __ ] die than not have air
conditioning [ __ ] that
somebody told me right now somebody came
in and said jenny you can't have air
conditioning anymore [ __ ] that i'm
moving yeah i'm moving to [ __ ] alaska
because [ __ ] that [ __ ] no way we're in
florida
yeah that's our life it is a life and
death situation people die without that
[ __ ] down here it's not funny
so yes this is dagobah i would
absolutely leave
if i had to live somewhere with no
arrogance okay look we gotta talk to
tammy and tammy's
okay so tammy's here well hold on
somebody said uh somebody asked if uh
the phantom was an incel yes yes he does
hint in the book yes they didn't say it
outright because it's 1909 but uh he
does hint that his dick doesn't work
yeah um he didn't say it like that
obviously um but the implication was
yeah his dick doesn't work well it
wouldn't he had actually never been
kissed by anyone yeah not even his mom
we're gonna get into that his dick
wouldn't work
it just wouldn't under the psychological
stresses that were on the phantom
if this is a true story that was one of
the things when i'm reading this i was
like this has got to be true because
everything was lining up in the damn
book when i was reading it if it's not
true it's based on a lot of [ __ ] that's
true
yeah um now
jenny's saying yeah which leaves me like
she thinking is fake was based on [ __ ]
the answer she's done a lot of real [ __ ]
it is the ancients and i'm going to say
victorians were anxious
they were very much like something out
of the roman era
uh the ancients understood human nature
very well
they didn't have scientific explanations
or vocabularies to explain it but they
knew human nature very well
and
dudes did what they were saying was
is that the phantom had performance
anxiety
and if you're a [ __ ] up dude you're
gonna have performance anxiety i mean if
your face looks like that yeah yeah i
can see that yeah
so i'm reading i'm going i think this
happened although like i said well and i
said this when we were talking about
dark man i was like i i think he looks
kind of cool
we're dealing with the victorian era and
the disease that you and i are talking
about we haven't mentioned it yet but
this yeah we'll get into that too
it would uh would give you bad
performance anxiety and it would explain
everything in this book
a serial killer with a certain disease
that was very common back then
that's what this was
if it existed yeah if it wasn't it was
made up of what they knew
where we'll see yeah we'll see yeah
let's talk about yeah so before we get
too much into it because i saw that
tammy was here now we did mention this
on one of our matinee shows earlier but
i said well i definitely wanted to bring
it back up on the main show because uh i
don't think tammy was here on the other
one um but thank you very much tammy she
sent us a box and we got it a couple
days ago
and she sent us this sweet card with the
little frog on it
and i'm gonna read it right now it's not
super long so don't get excited
uh just a little something to show my
appreciation for all the hard work you
do to put out all the content you do the
cookie butter which is this yeah we have
had cookie bottles we haven't tried we
haven't opened the cookie pack i've
opened the other candy though that's for
sure but um but yeah so here's the
cookie butter crunchy cooked i'm just
gonna i've had these like biscoff i love
these so yeah so she sent us that cookie
butter is
great on apple or banana slices i have
made truffles with it before which oh my
god i want some of those right now
uh the white chocolate i've already got
into these as you can see
you've been in the white chocolate yeah
oh [ __ ] give me one i just had a couple
of them yeah i've had a couple of them
they're like the lint truffles she says
the white chocolate is for jenny because
she said one time it was her favorite i
know
i look you can have one you can i got
chunky bar yeah you do um but yeah i
love white chocolate it is my favorite i
actually like it more than milk
chocolate usually in most applications
uh and also the chunkies yeah for a town
yeah give me a chunky book
i didn't even know they made these
anymore i thought that i remember these
from my childhood she was gone those are
pretty good i have to say yeah these are
good uh and of course i couldn't forget
the real star of the show
temptations for pookie
yeah yeah and she sent us a little bag
of temptations
the little surfer show she loves these
ones actually she's into seafood this is
a chunky bar it's a [ __ ] chocolate
bar with pizza and she also sent us some
money okay and said ps for anything oh
man that's awesome so that's that's a
[ __ ] time it's like 40 bucks thank you
thank you so much tammy you were so so
awesome
um
and i'm just like like i said i already
got into those like truffles because
hell yeah i'm gonna eat those how can i
have those in the same room in the same
office and not like eat them
i'm surprised i haven't eaten all of
them already because i had one with my
coffee today and it's like delicious i
love white chocolate pookie sees me
opening this packet of chocolate and
she's like what the [ __ ] is that you
want some
is it a meat stick don't want that don't
give her chocolate
it's chocolate you don't want this
kitties can't eat chocolate smelly
doggies can't eat smell it you'll see
you don't want it
then she'll probably lick it
i don't care
yeah she's like yucky she can lick some
and i'll eat it anyway
jenny's seen me do that she'll lick it
uh just no let's all eat it
well i i think i've done that too i
don't care
well i've even doubled
that yeah and the thing about it too is
like and maybe people think this is
weird but it's like i'll take my hair
brush and i'll brush her with it and
then i brush my hair
i don't get it she's a little baby she's
just a baby that's okay
um tammy says i found the chunkies at my
local walgreens
i wonder if our i wonder if our cvs up
the road has them i never noticed them
cbs doesn't happen i don't i don't think
i've ever seen them oh man it's got it's
got the raisins in it i told you there's
raisins in there it's always had raisins
in it
everybody had raised does it have nuts
in it or not mm-hmm
no not right now i don't want to eat on
camera because it's gross
i'll have one later
um
did pookie try the catnip flavored
temptations i gave this to my cat and
she loves it yeah she likes those
honestly i think her favorite ones are i
don't know she likes all of them really
she seems to like the red ones the
backyard cookout which i think is like a
combination of flavors it's like chicken
and beef and liver i think uh she likes
the seafood ones she even likes the milk
ones although the purple ones but those
are like her least favorite and she
likes the catnip ones too and the
chicken ones i feel like the chicken
ones are the ones we have most often
because i get a thing like from chewy
every six weeks and it has a chicken one
and a backyard cookout one and she seems
to like those just fine although
we got her some wet food which i think
is like some kind of chicken something
and now she started eating that and the
shiba meat sticks
and kind of like not turning her nose up
at the treats but then it's kind of like
well
i'll eat the wet food and the meat
sticks first and then if i'm still
hungry then i'll eat the treats so
there's that
uh yeah so i'm yeah i'm excited to try
the cookie butter i don't think i've
ever had
uh cookie butter before what is cookie
butter well it's just it's butter like
smooshed up but it's made of cookies
and it's chunky
so you put it on apples you could put on
a sandwich if you wanted to or toast oh
i gotta do this man well yeah he's like
what i didn't even know this [ __ ]
existed
you can just smush up cookies and make
like a butter out of it you can make a
butter yeah what kind of cookie that
kind of cookie the the these kind of
these biscuits
let me smell it
a sugar cookie
murder hornet said that we should get a
box of gifts next wednesday oh thank you
very much
okay
yeah um
yeah somebody said they can't taste
sweet things yeah um i don't think cats
have a sweet no they're not a sweet
receptor you try to offer them chocolate
they're like what's that although i used
to have a cat a long time ago that was
super into those donut sticks you know
that smells let me smell it
oh my god oh we're gonna have a good
time with that hold on i'm just gonna do
we have anything like a spoon um there's
some like underneath the underneath that
thing over there there's some like
plastic spoons underneath the sink there
in the cabinet okay there's a little box
of like plastic spoons behind all the
coffee and [ __ ]
it's behind the coffee uh it's like a
blue box i think
behind the coffee do you see it there's
like spoons and knives and [ __ ] no
that's sugar
he's like i don't it's over on like no
it's it's not at that end it's toward
this end
behind the coffee bags yeah there you go
dj maniac says we brush our teeth with
hair on a stick and we brush our hair
with teeth on a stick that's true
that's true
um
[Music]
okay you got one he's all right
oh
try it give me some of that
cookie butter oh my god
[ __ ] cookie butter that shit's
amazing
man i'm gonna make a sandwich for that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i've never heard of that
oh my god that's so good
i've had those kind of cookies before
but i've never had it in butter form and
it's actually much better just like
peanut butter but it's sweet it has
crunchy stuff in it it was cookies
kind of like um
man i want to make some like toast with
that what's the flavor
the flavor is kind of like cookie sugar
cookie
kinda yeah it's kind of it's um
those i think those biscoff are like
more european because i kind of feel
like those are like tea biscuits like
you have them with your tea yeah because
they taste like those um
uh like digestives and stuff like that
which i was always really into those
you're supposed they're kind of made to
like eat with tea
you know i mean tea or coffee yeah
they're good
that's really really good like i said
that'd be super good with the toast
aaron e came in thank you very much for
puking snacks thank you very much
thank you
yeah we probably need some more snacks i
just looked in the i looked in the
refrigerator earlier because i was
getting my snickers flavored coffee
creamer out and i was like man all
that's in our mini fridge is two things
of orange juice and that's it all of the
stuff that you bought
from dg
dg the dollar general all those snacks
you bought are all gone did you eat all
of those snacks yeah you must have
i didn't eat them there's cookies in
there i ate a couple of cookies but i
think that's good now okay
i just remember there was like a whole
bunch of packs of cookies and sodas and
all that kind of stuff and all that [ __ ]
they were out of the lemon
lemon cookies
lemon ones are the best
and look
here in the south we have dollar general
dollar
tree and what's the other one dollar
there's a lot of one well dollar tree
yeah that's kind of like well
everything's a dollar yeah they sold
some good [ __ ] in there though dollar
general is like shit's whatever
yeah it's a joke but it's generally
cheaper than
walmart or target yeah or whatever
usually not always you never can't tell
what's going to be in there and you
can't ever tell what's going to be yeah
it's always going to be different i mean
we have one like right next to our
neighborhood which is
like it's within walking distance pretty
much like i could walk to it if i wanted
to that was family dollar
that's right family dollar i think that
one that everything's not a dollar no
it's just whatever yeah whatever family
dollar is kind of like a mini walmart
yeah
yeah
but yeah it's not bad
it's poor people food dj maniac says no
everything's a dollar 25 now at dollar
tree yeah it hurt their prices were
going up yeah
i mean that was probably inevitable they
couldn't sustain that business model
dollar tree was originally supposed to
be everything was a dollar but it's not
yeah they had those in the uk too called
the pound shop yeah the thing is about
dollar general dollar general had
nothing to do with the us dollar nothing
evidently
from what i remember the dude that made
that store's last name was dollar so it
doesn't have anything to do with that i
think well i think company man on
youtube yeah which if you haven't
subscribed to him he's like really
interesting i like it he'll explain that
[ __ ] i think he did a show about dollars
like all dollar general dollar tree
family dollar i think he did a video
about that not too long ago yeah which
is yeah but uh dollar general the cool
thing about them is like they'll usually
open up in places where there aren't
many other options food deserts yeah um
which is kind of like well well ours
isn't that bad because like just like
less than a mile up the road we have a
publix and a you know and that didn't
used to be there but that didn't used to
be there so the dollar general right
next to that neighborhood that's where
you get most of your [ __ ] right i mean
they don't have a huge selection but
they do have a lot of
everything it saves you from having to
drive 15 miles that's all it is yeah
we're in america it's not like
it's not like [ __ ] we you can't get
supplied you can
it's just that the difference is do i
want to drive two miles yeah the
difference is lazy 20 miles
right that's all it is not so much
laziness i just don't like to drive
really far yeah like if i can get
something like obviously publix has
better [ __ ] food food wise like by a
long stretch
but if i'm too lazy to drive that far
and it's something that isn't all that
like if it's just you know like coffee
or sugar or something like that i'm just
gonna get a dollar general and get it i
don't want to drive all the way to
[ __ ] publix to get that even though
all the way it's like less than a mile i
think dollar general had [ __ ] that you
couldn't get at [ __ ] publix like
little round ham cans
for two dollars a big piece of [ __ ]
ham
i bought a bunch of them it was good
you know i like i will say though that i
really like and i think i mentioned this
before i really got into like all these
youtube videos
of people that were just going because
they were trying to like help out people
that only lived by a dollar tree or a
dollar general and they're like showing
how you could make actual food with the
stuff you could buy there yeah you can
make a lot because some dollar generals
and dollar trees have a refrigerated
section and some don't yeah so sometimes
you have to you know buy the dry food
but they were showing how you could make
actual food with [ __ ] you could get
there like for cheap you can get a dozen
eggs for a dollar 25
yeah which that's that's pretty cheap
even here i mean eggs are kind of like
the ideal like
broke-ass person food right there's a
lot of cheese and a lot of [ __ ]
coffee and it's a general store you can
buy anything you can get all your bacon
there's enough stuff to bake a couple
different kinds of cakes
um cake mix eggs oil
you can even get cool [ __ ] like salsa
avocado salsa mexican stuff
you know just you you're looking at it
and you're going like well you know
this is actually a pretty good selection
for being a po duck [ __ ] store i mean
you just gotta be creative you gotta be
creative you gotta be creative good
um you know but it can be done like you
can actually like it's not ideal no they
don't obviously have a lot of like fresh
vegetables or anything like that which
is canned oysters but yeah but you can
find some stuff that you can actually
like mix together and make canned
tomatoes canned [ __ ]
tuna you know can't ham and that's all
cheap
so dj maniac says we have a store here
called big lots yeah we have that we got
it here we have big lots here too uh
which is more or less a discount store
yeah
yeah we i used to uh shop at the one at
um daytona i one time i was at big lots
they got one just up the street here
i went to big lots and got a case
of [ __ ] energy drinks it was [ __ ]
um
cran uh
not cranberry pomegranate flavor energy
drink i remember what it was random yes
pomegranate
it was all star rock star
rock star pomegranate got a whole
[ __ ] case of it which is like six six
packs
for 15 bucks
damn
yeah like well yeah
that's cheap well it was discontinued
yeah
you know that
big lots is where you go to go get some
[ __ ] well that's where they offload the
[ __ ] they're getting ready we don't sell
this anymore and it's like sitting in
our you know stinking up our warehouse
or
it's damaged or the packaging was
printed wrong or something or something
like that
you know so you get it like for a lot
yeah but big lots
the quality is good
the quality is i actually bought a lot
of [ __ ] for my first apartment i bet yes
you know quality is good and the price
is [ __ ] like cheese and [ __ ] yeah
but they'll you can even go there and
like buy a model kit
yeah you know like models and [ __ ]
models of the [ __ ] starship
enterprise and [ __ ] you'll have that in
big lots
but you never can't tell nothing's
reliable it's just what they're whatever
they're trying to get rid of yeah so you
can't really count on oh i need to get
this that and the other and having a
list you just have to go in there and go
be like what do they got because they
don't always have the same thing you go
in there and get a big old [ __ ] pot
[ __ ] a five gallon pot that you could
hold you could you could damn
deep fry a turkey in
and other in another place it might be
40 bucks or 30 bucks for that pot but in
big lots you might be able to get it for
five
but you'll never find that pot again
it's just that particular pot
you know that's the way it is
uh tyler says i love dollar general
because you find all kind of weird cool
and weird stuff in there yeah i do yeah
um i mean they have you never know what
they're gonna have in there yeah i went
in there the other day and spent like a
hundred dollars buying like just some
random like [ __ ] from around the house
like little storage things and like
[ __ ]
paint and all kind of stuff they got a
toy section that blew my mind they were
in there they were selling halo action
figures in the halo video game i was
just looking at it
i was going like man if i was [ __ ] 12
i would [ __ ] love that [ __ ] well yeah
but they were only like [ __ ] five or
six bucks for like a whole [ __ ]
a whole kit of [ __ ] halo action
figures
you just never can't tell what's gonna
be in there
i mean if it was just you could probably
just buy that and like hang on to it for
a little while maybe probably worth
something i don't know yeah i don't know
enough about a little not at all either
to judge yeah uh zach says i love how as
this convo is going down i'm making some
microwavable loaded potatoes oh those
are good those are yeah that's that's
bacon bits sour cream chives [ __ ]
cheese hell yeah dj maniac then says
five below oh yeah we have some of those
too is where they offload dead stock too
everything is five dollars yeah i bought
a bunch of the gi joe retaliation
figures there that i never found at
retail and they're worth a fortune oh
yeah yeah i would imagine
yeah i always go through the toy aisle
just in case
yeah you never know what might turn up
in there
wait a minute hold on [ __ ] a big ass
darth vader yeah i want that you know
what i mean
you don't know what's going to be in
there
usually usually it's something like
star wars or video games or [ __ ]
marvel or you never can't tell
jason heeby dad says i remember
poundland that's kind of like the
british equivalent was the kind of place
with uh gray sprayed chewbacca figures
and a pick a picture little millennium
falcon with a generic name like space
battles yeah yeah yeah
yeah like like off-brand stuff yeah here
they're just like they would be the real
thing i mean here they do have some
off-brand [ __ ] at these but a lot of
times it'll be like the real thing but
it's just like you know
it's the overstock or something that was
discontinued or something they couldn't
sell and it's just you know yeah a lot
of times it's it's the real thing it's
just that they couldn't sell it
somewhere else
and they're just trying to get rid of it
and you look at it you go like it's star
wars figures from three years ago
you know that haven't sold
but it's almost on the verge of being a
collectible now because [ __ ]
are aging out three years ago
so you just you just can't tell you just
to be you got to be smart about it yeah
when you buy it yeah james knapp says
you started the show yet um we did but
then we got distracted yeah he's going
to start the show this guy's done he's
going to touch it
so i felt kind of bad but you know what
i mean i was just kind of like i'm gonna
uh make another drink for you yeah
because we did kind of like talk a lot
about it
yeah at the beginning how long we've
been doing this uh 47 for almost 48
minutes you guys know the first hour is
always us [ __ ] warming up anyway yeah
we gotta get like we gotta get loosened
up with the with the liquor
but uh but yeah so we did talk about it
like to some extent but then again like
like usual we got distracted because
that's how we do we have add probably
undiagnosed i kind of feel like because
we're just go off on these [ __ ]
tangents
um but yeah so uh before he gets back
let me tom and jenny got distracted no
way yeah it happens it happens
you know
um all right
so let's talk a little bit about
just kind of the background i kind of
feel like i don't know i don't know how
familiar um people are with the
background of the original novel of
phantom of the opera because i know that
a lot of people especially nowadays are
probably more familiar with
the stuff that came in the way because i
feel like nowadays probably the most
popular one is like the andrew lloyd
webber like stage musical right like i
kind of feel like most people think of
that when they think of phantom of the
opera rather than the original book or
you know the lon chaney movie or
whatever um and i kind of we kind of
wanted to talk a lot about
the original novel
and how
what parts of it were maybe like based
on reality or not and i kind of got
really interested in like uh researching
that kind of stuff
so the novel originally um you know
obviously written by gaston leroux who
is a french author
now it first started out as a serial
so i guess it was published
in a publication called um and please
forgive me i did take four years of
french but that was a long time ago so
i'm sure my pronunciation is really
terrible um but there was a publication
called la galwa
and so this came out like there was a
chapter in there
like every week or every month or
whatever
between september of 1909 and january of
1910
and then a couple months after that like
in spring of 1910 it was released like
in book form
uh in you know by a publisher
now
the novel
it's pretty well acknowledged that
the novel
is based on some real [ __ ] that happened
the
controver i don't want to say
controversy because it's not like that
but
there's some
it's not really clear
how much of the story
is
like the real
kind of plot of the story the character
of eric stuff like that is that based on
a real person
um
or
is it just like a really well-crafted
combination of
real [ __ ]
legend and fiction
so there's that i didn't realize
actually how much of the stuff in the
book is
based on real things he did set it in a
real location
some of the people are based on real
people even though they're not named the
same thing
so there's that as well so that's kind
of like where the kernel of this idea
came from because tom said something to
me i don't even i don't even know like
where you got the idea from because you
just said to me like one night we were
like sitting around watching tv or
whatever and you said oh i was like
watching a thing about phantom of the
opera
or you were rereading phantom of the
opera or something and you said oh it
was like maybe based on a real thing and
you got like really interested in it you
said maybe we should do a show about
that and then i put it in the poll and
it won and then when i started like
looking into it i'm like wow this is
like really interesting do you know what
i mean i didn't realize
how much of it was like based on uh real
[ __ ]
so i don't remember what it was that
brought it up yeah i can't i can't
remember either it was like it was last
man it was last week maybe i think
dartmouth
although i thought you said well now i
can't remember
yeah maybe maybe it was because we've
been watching dark man which has like
some aspects of phantom of the opera to
it
and then you thought of phantom with
opera and then you said oh we were like
yeah so we i think i went you know i
think that was based on something that
actually happened maybe we got to do a
show on it
yeah
now i will say like just from the outset
a lot of the stuff in there
is based on stuff that really happened
in the sense that
he took real events
and i think like woven narrative around
them
but some of the events i'm not really
sure it's not very clear over whether
the stuff really happened or whether it
was like
a legend like an urban legend type
situation you know what i mean so said
leroy's background was a reporter yeah
he was a mad skills research yes he knew
paris yeah and i looked up into it
and on wikipedia it said that he was on
his deathbed people were asking him
about it he said that he actually did
that it actually did happen
that he researched it he believed at
least that it happened
we'll see yeah we'll get into that okay
um now one of the things that is
acknowledged that he um
put into the story that inspired the
story
uh was for sure
an urban legend
one of the things that inspired the
story was there was this story going
around
that there was a production
of the opera
der freischutz
uh which actually i think means the
marksman or something like that
uh staged by uh carl maria von weber in
1841
and there had been a rumor going around
that i guess there's a scene in that
where there's a skeleton and that they
had actually used a real skeleton of
like a ballet dancer that had died like
they used it in the production i don't
think that really happened but there was
like an urban legend about it and it was
like pretty widespread
and so that was one of the things that
like inspired him to write it but you
know we'll get into like some some of
the other [ __ ] too but that was one of
the things for real that was going
around because that's a pretty
widespread uh urban legend
um so yeah
obviously uh this has a million
adaptations most people familiar with
the uh andrew lloyd
webber musical which you know started in
1986 i think is
the first or second longest running uh
musical in the west end i can't remember
i think it might be the second longest
running uh so massive massive success
and i think that most people know it
from that which uh is amazing but you
know it's based on the book it's you
know fairly faithful to the book but
there's a lot of different [ __ ] in the
book uh that's in there it's they
changed a lot
um i will say the 1925 version with lon
chaney
the movie is not it's not super faithful
but at least like the way that he looks
is like more the way that the phantom
looked in the book
also now
what you were talking about like the
prologue of this book i'm not going to
read the whole thing because it's it's
not super long but it's a little bit
long you can go to gutenberg.org which
is where all the public domain stuff is
and you can read fan of the opera for
yourself um like i said i listened to
the audiobook earlier like over the last
couple days
and uh so i kind of like uh you know
had some familiarity with it
but the prologue which is supposedly
written from the point of view of
gasoline himself
he says in the prologue
the opera ghost which is what he's
called during the story he's not called
the phantom of the opera or nothing like
that he's called the opera ghost or the
og which i thought was very funny
because he's that's how he signs his
letters like when he signs when he sends
letters in the book it says oh gee and
i'm just like
he's the original gangsta yeah that's
right i thought that was really funny
every time i heard that like in the
audiobook i cracked up
but yeah so uh so he says the opera
ghost really existed
he was not as was long believed a
creature of the imagination of the
artist the superstition of the managers
or a product of the absurd and
impressionable brains of the young
ladies of the ballet yeah those dumb
ballet dancers their mothers the box
keepers the cloak room attendants or the
concierge yes he existed in flesh and
blood although he assumed the complete
appearance of a real phantom that is to
say of a spectral shade
when i began to ransack the archives of
the national academy of music i was at
once struck by the surprising
coincidences between the phenomena
ascribed to the ghost and the most
extraordinary and fantastic tragedy that
ever excited the paris upper classes and
i soon conceived the idea that this
tragedy might reasonably be explained by
the phenomena in question
he then goes on in the prologue to
basically say yeah i did all this
research and he kind of names
some of the people who appear in the
story and he's like yeah i read this
person's memoirs and this that and the
other and he's like and they all
insisted to me that everything that was
written in there was true and so that's
why there's still a question nowadays
like people still ask
was the phantom of the opera based on a
true story
and i will say
sort of
it's sort of based on a true story some
of the stuff that happened in there
did actually happen
but some of the stuff in there
no one's super sure about it could just
be
like a legend you know what i mean in
the mod okay what you're telling me
when you say it's sort of based on
something true
by today's standards that's almost like
saying yes
we'll see we'll see
what he's well i mean you'll see what
i'm talking about yeah
aspects of it are based on real things
okay are based on real things okay
the story has totality i had a feeling
not so much i had a feeling that this is
based on [ __ ] they knew about but okay
go ahead
so do should we do a plot synopsis okay
because like i said i kind of feel like
unless everybody says no we already know
that story but i do kind of feel like
even though there's been a lot of
adaptations of it
i do kind of feel like
the adaptations are different enough
from the book i don't know if enough
people have read the book to know the
actual like plot that i'm saying the
book the [ __ ] that happens in the book
is very plausible if you have modern
understanding of serial killers you're
like yeah that [ __ ] probably did happen
but we'll see what jenny says about it i
mean
i don't know what she's dug up yet
you know yeah i think of all kind of fun
stuff it's fun okay so let's do a plot
sign up so this is of the novel now
so the novel is said in the
1880s okay which
you know he wrote it in 1909 so and he
says in the prologue that it was uh the
[ __ ] that happened was about 30 years
ago that's what he says in the prologue
now this is set at a real opera house
which is still there and you can go
there to this day if you want uh they
don't do operas there so much anymore
it's mostly now for ballet
uh but it's still there
called the palais garnier
now uh in the setting like this opera
house supposedly haunted by uh an entity
known as the opera ghost like i said or
the og which that's very funny
uh so very early in the story they find
a stagehand whose name is joseph bouquet
and he is found hanging
now
this somebody finds him and then they
run off to tell somebody as you would
and then when they come back like the
dude's still dead but the rope is gone
which seems a little suspicious so
there's that so there's one person dead
at first
now no one's too worried about that
apparently because they jump to this big
uh
kind of thing that they're doing
the two managers of the opera house
are retiring so they're having kind of
like a big gala party type of thing
so at this party they have this woman
singing
uh christine daye
now she is very young and she's not
that that well-known uh she's swedish
um so she
actually gets called on to sing in place
of
the kind of diva you know the prima
donna of the place whose name is
carlotta who is a spanish soprano
she's sick
so christine daye gets called in to sing
for her
christine
sings like
holy [ __ ] like everyone is just kind of
like this is the voice of heaven huh
like come down to like [ __ ] you know
to suck a butt
[Laughter]
never know when him to grace the mortals
uh everyone is just astonished at this
young woman who has seemingly come out
of nowhere and is singing like a [ __ ]
angel all of a sudden everyone's just
like flipping out about how it was back
then i guess so everything was in person
well yeah they didn't have tv or the
internet or not you had to actually go
and see something you see it you're like
whoa and it was just like yeah it was
super impressive
so it so happens that there's a guy at
this performance uh na who's the vi
count vi count raul which we'll call him
de chanye that's what his name is but
we'll call him raul
and he sees her up there and says hey i
know that [ __ ] yeah
i know that [ __ ]
i'm writing the i'm writing the jenny's
version doesn't say that in the actual
novel um he says hey i remember her me
and her grew up together we were like
friends when we were little yeah
um and i was like super in love with her
back in the day and then he kind of
realizes and i think i'm still kind of
in love with her because she's pretty
awesome so there's that it's got a tight
ass i guess you could bounce a quarter
off that yep
also she sings really good yeah
um so he goes to visit her but i have to
say reading this book again because like
i said i read it when i was a teenager i
think and i hadn't read it since then so
i reread it uh over the last couple days
for the show
and i was like raul
kind of sucks he's he's not really that
great like i'm not saying the phantom's
any better
i'm just saying that christine
really needed to either just be single
or find like a way better dude than
either of these two because the options
are just really not raul was just like
slightly less of a murdery dick because
he's still kind of a dick he didn't kill
anybody i don't think but he's still
kind of a dick though
so raul says oh i'm gonna go like
backstage
so he goes backstage and he listens at
her dressing room door
and hears her talking to somebody like
talking to a man
and he gets kind of like even though he
seriously all he did was like sit in the
audience and listen to her saying and be
like hey i remember i love that girl and
i think i still love her and then he
goes back and listens he hasn't even
talked to her yet or nothing and he's
listening to her at the door
and then he gets mad because he's like
oh she he that [ __ ] has like a man in
that room
and you know and then he gets all like
butthurt about it and then she like
comes out and he goes in there afterward
but there's nobody in there he's like
what the [ __ ] okay who would the who the
[ __ ] was doctor
um so at this point raoul
goes to christine and like gets all
in her face about like who is that in
your room
and uh she doesn't like tell him to [ __ ]
off which you know which i would have
done
but says oh
um that's the angel of music
because then she goes into this long
thing like her when she was a kid
her dad who was like this master
violinist
he told her like before he died he said
i'm when i die i'm gonna go to heaven
and i'm gonna tell
the angel of music because she was like
super talented like uh musically so i'm
gonna tell the angel of music to come
and visit you
and train you in music so you'll be like
super awesome
so i'm gonna do that so she believed
that
and
so this voice that's been talking to her
in her dressing room she actually
believes is this angel of music that was
sent to her by her dad
so
she tells uh raul that and he straight
up laughs at her face
which like i said i'm listening to this
audiobook i'm like man what an [ __ ]
because she like very seriously like
very earnestly says that's the angel of
music he talks to me like in my dressing
room and he's like what the [ __ ] what
the hell's the matter with you so yeah
um roll just says i think somebody's
like playing a prank and she's just like
[ __ ] off and she runs away
now uh there's also a thing where he
follows her because again raul he's not
really much better i gotta say so he
follows her
and uh she goes to her dad's grave
and he hears this like beautiful violin
music which
i kind of think for a second he maybe
thinks is like her dad playing the
violin from beyond the grave because
like i said he was like a super hot
violent player
and um
but then he sees like this weird figure
like this dark figure and he like tries
to
like jump on it but it gets away
and he gets knocked out
so back at the opera house uh there are
the new managers have taken over now
there's a lot of stuff in the book where
the new managers these two guys
um are kind of like
the comic relief i want to say
because it kind of like goes back and
forth and i know this was like
serialized at first but it kind of goes
back and forth like to these two new
managers um and they're just like
absolutely convinced that this whole
opera ghost thing is the biggest prank
ever so they're trying to like figure
out what the [ __ ] is going on with it
and trying to like uncover who's behind
it because they just think the whole
thing's ridiculous
um but they get a letter
from the opera ghost or the og
and uh the og says he sends these
letters that are
very articulate they're always in red
ink
and uh but they're kind of like the
handwriting is kind of like looks like a
kid's handwriting a little bit like it
says in the book
so basically the og he has like all of
these things he's like look i had this
uh situation with the old managers where
they paid me what was it 200 000 francs
it was like some huge sum and they paid
me um you know this once a month and
they they kept aside like box five
for me and they couldn't sell it because
that's my box
and uh so he had like demands you know
what i'm saying
and uh so he's like so we had an
arrangement so are we gonna have the new
arrangement but the new managers are
like yeah we are not having this
arrangement because we think this is
like a prank
so basically this letter says that um
you have to let christine
be it be um the role of marguerite and
faust
like [ __ ] that carlotta chick
and uh also he says you have to leave
box five empty all the time because i
use it
um
or if you don't do that then he
basically says then your opera house
will have a curse on it that's what he
says
uh so again the managers are just kind
of like [ __ ] this this is crazy we're
not like cow towing to like some [ __ ]
random like opera goes what the [ __ ] and
like people keep coming to them there
are like many scenes of like people
coming to them being like look we've
seen the opera ghost um it's no joke and
he they're just like what the [ __ ] ever
what even we can't even so they're just
trying to like get to the bottom of it
but like i said a lot of it's kind of
like funny they keep going back and
forth
uh so they ignore the
demands of the opera ghost
uh and they'll they sell box five to
like some other [ __ ] you know
they do other things that piss the
phantom off uh they let carlotta sing
sing marguerite instead of christine
and so basically what happens because
carlotta sings the role that christine
was supposed to sing
uh at one point and i'm not entirely
sure how the phantom does this i guess
it's because of like i guess it's
ventriloquy because they do kind of
explain at the end like in a scooby-doo
sort of way like how
like well no it is kind of like that
like how the phantom did all the [ __ ]
because he wasn't like supernatural he
was just like a guy
but he had like all these kind of like
talents so he could do stuff but at one
point like carlotta is singing the role
and she's like super awesome and
everybody's like oh my god it's so
awesome she's the best and all this
other stuff and then like during one uh
during one arya i think she starts like
croaking
or like quacking like a duck
and she can't and like she tries to like
sing again and she's like sings and it's
like quacking
and then she's like [ __ ] man what the
hell is going on and everybody it's
funny like the description of this like
crack me up like when i was listening to
it because everybody
they're like well if it had been anybody
but her like everyone would immediately
have just started heckling yeah but
because it was her it was carlotta it
was like this big like it's [ __ ]
carlotta
and the sec likes and she's perfect and
then she like was singing and then she
started like croaking and then
everyone's like just went totally silent
like they couldn't like figure out what
the [ __ ] was going on and she couldn't
figure out what the [ __ ] was going on
like i said it might have been a
ventriloquy thing they i don't
know if they ever like really uh
established that
but so yeah so she does that and then
there's like a big thing where the
chandelier like after that happens like
the chandelier falls down into the
audience and crushes the person that um
this woman that was in the it's like it
wounds a lot of people obviously but it
kills this one woman
who
she was the woman that the new managers
had hired to take the place of the box
manager
from the phantoms box because he
basically said i want her to stay here
madame geary her name was he's like i
want her to stay here because she
already she's been here forever she
already knows what i like and she's
actually been to the new manager and
said hey
the opera ghost is real um i haven't
seen him but i've heard him talking to
me he leaves me tips um you know and he
has like a particular kind of like way
he likes things and you shouldn't [ __ ]
with it
and the new managers fired her because
they thought she was nuts
and that was one of his conditions was
like i want her reinstated but they
didn't reinstate her they fired her and
they hired this new woman
and the new woman was sitting in the
crowd and the chandelier comes down and
kills her
so there's that
now uh basically what happens too uh
then the phantom comes and kidnaps
christine from the dressing room
and takes her down to his lair like
underneath the opera house have you told
them who the phantom is supposed to be
well we haven't got to that yet okay we
haven't got that yet i'll get to that
let's just be patient
[Laughter]
tyler says the phantom sounds like an
in-cell serial killer version of batman
he is kinda kinda and dark man
yeah well that's why we we brought up
jar well like i said when we were
talking about dark man like sam raimi
wanted like a superhero movie but based
on like old universal movies like
hunchback of notre dame invisible man
uh you know uh phantom of the opera that
kind of stuff so there was that too
so
so he kidnaps her
and says okay so i'm actually
uh not a ghost i'm a deformed person
named eric now prior to this
people all around the opera house people
work there like the dancers and stuff
had seen him around
and they always described him the same
way and like i said in the movies
especially like after like post the
andrew lloyd
webber one i kind of feel like they kind
of just made him oh like just half his
face is a little bit [ __ ] up and there
was like the half mask which we'll get
into why they did that later but
in the original book he looks really
[ __ ] up
um they said he basically looks like a
walking corpse like
like he's skeletal he's super super
skinny like he's always well dressed
but he looks like a skeleton and his
face looks like a skull
and uh so when they see him they see
like the skull face but sometimes he has
a mask on but it's usually like a full
face mask i'll get into that later too
but they said he looks like a skull and
like his eyes are like weight are so far
back in his sockets that they look like
just so like sockets like without eyes
in them but then they're like kind of
glow like a cat's eyes like in the dark
so there's that too he's not magical
though he's just a dude
but
you know they're they're i guess they're
kind of like trying to build up a little
bit as being like fun a little bit
supernatural but
um so basically he takes christine
down to the lair
for a few days
now she takes his mask off and sees his
[ __ ] up face
and he says to her well um
now that you've seen my face you're
gonna leave so now i can't let you leave
so now you have to stay here forever
um but christine she stays there for a
couple weeks and then she's like okay
well
he's like i'll let you leave if you wear
my ring
like a wedding ring type thing
and like don't [ __ ] around with other
dudes yeah basically but she probably
wasn't good yeah she's basically your
mind now
so she talks her way out of the [ __ ]
probably you know smart
um
so at this point like she runs off and
tells raul who like i said it's not a
great deal better but i mean it's like
you know it's a step up i guess so she
tells raul um yeah this phantom opera
ghost percy it's a real person it's not
a ghost he kidnapped me
and um
you have to like get me the [ __ ] out of
here because he's gonna like kidnap me
and kill me maybe i don't know what the
[ __ ] he's gonna do
um
so raul says okay i'll do that
but what christine decides to she feels
bad for eric
uh the phantom and she's like well okay
tonight i'll sing one last thing i'll
because i feel bad i'll sing one last
thing just so it's kind of like a
goodbye type situation even though the
phantom doesn't know that's what it is
but because uh
because christine and raul apparently
have no peripheral vision they don't see
that the phantom listens to their whole
entire conversation and knows the whole
[ __ ] plan
so uh he gets mad obviously so he
abducts christine again like when
they're doing faust and basically says
you have to marry me or else
um at this point like raul
comes in contact with the opera regular
known as the persian who is apparently
the person who
in the lore of the story the persian is
the guy that told all of this story to
gaston larue
you know what i mean like he was the guy
that he hit the letters too yeah
apparently that's that's who this
character supposedly is so the persian
uh meets up with raul
and uh they're like okay we have to go
get christine back so they go down to
the bowels of the opera house
um and they end up in what is
essentially like a series of like
torture chamber type things he has like
a whole he's been busy down there the
phantom
uh there's this one room and it's like a
bunch of mirrors
and basically he traps them in there i
think there's a room too where he like
can can he like heat it up and like make
it like dry them out or something i
remember it was the same room
yes a room
i guess it was an octagon
with mirrors
the octagon yeah
and in the center it had a
metallic tree with razor sharp
leaves on it that would rotate
and it had crystals on the end of it
crystal leaves yeah and light shining on
it like i said it would spin
like a merry-go-round
and evidently kind of like would make
music when it would go kind of like a uh
kind of like a what do you call it a
music box
yeah and it had central heating
it would pump hot air into it
and the idea was is that it would make
you think that you were out in the
middle of a desert
around a [ __ ] silver tree
and the idea was to kind of dehydrate
you like you're in the desert
and uh make you go insane
from crazy music and you would climb up
on the tree
and uh hurt yourself on these [ __ ]
razor sharp
leaves
that was from what i remembered from the
book
it didn't work in the book
though it was just
it would it was supposed to take days to
kill you and the guy that they traveled
was only in there for a few hours
but uh it was kind of a
it had lights that came in through the
ceiling if i remember correctly and they
were kind of like gas lamps
that uh shone through magnifying glasses
if i remember correctly
from the ceiling because oh so it so it
had things that were like high tech for
the 1800s overhead lighting
gas powered overhead lighting
a tree that rotated that was like a
music box
and central heating
you know it didn't get like 200 degrees
it got like a hundred and something
degrees in there like like like the
desert
but if you were in there long enough
yeah that water yeah right you're
supposed to be in there you're supposed
to kill you
dying of thirst and make you insane yeah
so plausible plausible kind of like
something that h.h holmes maybe would
wish that he had
and according to the book
and eric's background he would have had
the intelligence and the money to do
this
because he had money according to the
book well as i said i mean he had money
from before and also he was getting like
essentially a stipend yeah from the
previous managers of the opera house
yeah they were giving i think it was 200
000 francs if i remember it's like i was
i was listening to it like over the last
couple days i think it was 200 and i
don't know what that is in today's money
it sounds like a lot of money but
they're giving it to him like every
month then there was like kind of a plot
point where the new managers didn't want
to do any of this [ __ ] because they
didn't believe the opera ghost was real
yeah so there was a lot of like [ __ ]
going back i don't know if you mentioned
it or not because i've been in and out
of the room but uh according to the book
eric had worked
as an interrogator and torturer
for a middle eastern
uh potentate yeah i mean i'll yeah i'll
get into that in a little bit like i
said i'm just doing kind of like a plot
synopsis and then i'll kind of get into
but yeah they do kind of go into eric's
backstory
a lot of eric's backstory is kind of
relegated to the prologue yeah and some
of his character is based on
um
a a guy who may or may not have existed
like uh like a legend about a guy
according to the bookies weren't working
for a sultan if if yeah it was a sultan
yeah uh did they say that what country
it was
um i can't remember i thought it was
[ __ ] i think he just said arabia
i don't remember if it was maybe arabia
or persia i think it was persia persia
so or maybe turkey iran or turkey
and evidently according to the book from
what i remember he was working for a
rich dude
uh a king basically
and he was a genius
a right-hand man to the king in the
intelligence community
doing
in intel work with [ __ ] torturing the
king's enemies making a bunch of money
and um engineering defenses and
buildings
and palaces for this sultan and he had a
[ __ ] ton of money
plausible
plausible but i don't know if it
actually happened but it does explain
where all this money came from
and uh for when i remember he kept
himself covered up
and was basically just a high
a high caliber
architect
and
uh intelligence operative for some
sultan
that plausible
i don't know if it actually happened
though we'll we'll see what jenny says
oracle says uh the persian is the
closest thing the story has to a real
hero i may have opinions on the subject
no i agree with you on that i agree with
you on that well that was one of the
weird things about the story when i was
reading about it it doesn't have a
classical structure of heroes and
villains in a certain way
everyone kind of sucks yeah everyone
kind of sucks well christine doesn't
suck she's just like an innocent but
like all the dudes in this are kind of
terrible there is not a big varying
degree there's not a big difference
between them even eric who's the phantom
has an element of victim to him i mean
he's kind of
he didn't choose this you know it was i
was kind of struck by because i already
knew that like the phantom was like kind
of like the villain even though he's a
sympathetic villain he's still
absolutely a villain
i was kind of struck rereading the book
about how much of a [ __ ] raul was yeah
who was supposedly you know that he was
kind of like the white knight or the guy
that was going to save her and he was
still kind of a douche
i mean he just yeah i mean it was [ __ ]
like that that made me believe that
gaston what godstone was saying is that
it may have been that this may have been
something that actually happened well i
don't know if it was so much that but it
was just the conventions of the time
yeah it's kind of just like because i
kind of feel like whenever because i
read a lot of um horror stories and
stuff like that from this period and
that's just kind of like what the
conventions at the time were normally
black and white um yeah like good people
and honestly even the heroes in a lot of
horror stories like if they're men
are act like this and that's just like
the way men acted so it's like nobody
thought that it was like nowadays you'd
be like what the [ __ ] what an [ __ ]
yeah but back then i guess nobody
thought he was an [ __ ] yeah he's
totally an [ __ ] as i read it back in
the very early 2000s it just had a
[ __ ] ring of truth to it
although maybe gaston fooled me i mean i
don't know i think he might have okay
although i have to say yeah i really
like
and i'm gonna say like i said nobody
knows it was a long time ago but if he
did do it i was like it's pretty genius
the way he
kind of um wove together
reality cause like i said a lot of the
stuff was based on real [ __ ]
and fiction in a way that people are
still asking about it nowadays
i just kind of feel like
he swore that it happened but we'll see
i know but
we'll see we'll get into that a little
bit we'll just say but yeah you know how
jenny is
well i'm skeptical
i'm natural i'm most acceptable but
there's something very human about this
story
i mean something like this might have
happened but something to this degree
seems unlikely to me but a lot of the
aspects of it are based on real [ __ ]
that happens so i will say that but
we'll get into that a little bit i'm
still doing the plot synopsis
uh so yeah
so at this point like i said uh so
there's the torture chamber raul and uh
and uh and
uh
the persian are in there yeah i couldn't
remember for a second
they're in the secret lair they're
trapped in the mirror room
and uh the phantom basically says to
christine
you have to marry me or i'm gonna blow
this whole [ __ ] up and he shows her he
has like a whole room full of like big
barrels full of gunpowder
and he shows you these two things these
two like levers kind of uh one of them
has a grasshopper on it and one of them
has a scorpion on it the grasshopper one
he's like that means that you don't want
to marry me that means the opera house
is gonna blow up the scorpion one if you
turn that that means you will marry me
and it'll flood the room with the
gunpowder get it all wet and so it won't
work
um and at this point she's kind of like
well wait maybe they both will make the
ship blow up you know what i mean but
she's like well okay i'll marry you fine
um i don't want you to blow up
everything
so she does it uh and it does work it
does actually like flood the [ __ ] but
um it also starts to flood the chamber
that the persian and raoul are in oh it
should be noted too that earlier eric
drowned
raul's brother
uh who had come down there looking for
raul
so he drowned him too so again just a
vic victim count is pretty high
um he kills a bunch of people so she
does agree to marry him
um
now basically she's like okay um i'll
just i'll be your wife just spare them
you know that's what she says
she offers to be his quote unquote
living bride
because i i'm not really sure what the
implications of that were i think that
she was going to kill herself
and
like initially
um after they got married but then she
said no i'll actually like stay alive
and like endure the marriage
if you don't
kill raul and the persian
you know
uh so eric does actually release them
from the torture chamber
so eric then uh he's alone with
christine and he picks his mask up which
like i said it's a full face mask it's
not the half mask it's not the
domino mask it's not that it's a full
face he picks and it's black in the book
it's not white
so he picks it up
and um kisses her forehead
and she
kisses him back
and this blows his mind so much because
he says he's never been kissed before
even even by his mother
um and this
like flips him out to such a degree
that uh
people talk about people being
snowflakes nowadays holy crap back then
it's like you have like some little
emotion everybody's just like men and
women are both like [ __ ] fainting all
over the place they just can't take it
so he's so overcome
that she would kiss him back willingly
kind of
um that he just starts like sobbing and
breaking down and [ __ ] like that
um and she says you know she kind of
like hugs eminence like talks about how
sorry she is for him
and
uh then he just like is reduced to like
a blubbering mess pretty much
now
basically then he lets christine go but
he says you have to come back when i'm
gonna die you have to come back and
visit me and return the ring that i gave
you
um and he says to the persian
um go to the newspaper and report my
death because i'm gonna die soon because
all this love
is overwhelming me man and i just can't
take it because i've never had it before
which is like that's sad but like i said
victorians
so there was that
so
christine goes back to eric's lair after
he dies just like she promised she would
and she buries him
where he won't be found and returns the
gold ring to his finger
and then apparently uh this according to
the book
a local newspaper runs a little ad or a
little uh you know article that says
eric is dead that's all it says
and then christine and raul
uh run off together and get married
why'd you marry rubble just you could
have done better girl just saying rubble
was such a jerk
i mean you know what i mean he was just
he that's one thing that struck me like
re-reading this book i'm like god
bravo's a jerk god damn it like i said
the phantom he's a villain so it's like
everybody like expects him to be
terrible but raul was supposed to be the
hero nominally and i was like he's still
kind of an [ __ ] though
holy [ __ ] i think godstone was good with
writing
he didn't want to it's a fun book i had
a good time like re-reading he didn't
wanna i guess
i guess he didn't want people to sound
perfect or stereotypical kind of like
they were usually back then i don't know
but
i don't know do you think these people
actually existed
some of them are based on real people
yeah
but
we'll get into that okay so in the
epilogue
uh gaston larue talks about
eric's uh backstory
now he says that he got this info from
the persian who he says is like a real
person although we don't think he ever
names who the persian is but he was
supposedly like that persian regular
yeah the persian guy the only one well
in the
only non-white person
he had a hard time finding everybody who
saw this convenient and
he was like
it was 20 something years and they all
[ __ ] moved on and
everything had changed in france during
that during all that time and
he said he eventually did find this guy
and after talking to him it turned out
that he had some letters written from
the phantom to the girl
and that he read them and he checked out
the handwriting
because he knew the girl's handwriting
and he said that
he said he first he thought they were
forged
because it was too good to be true
but then he said and she did kind of say
in the prologue that it's like some of
the all this [ __ ] could be forged she
didn't kind of say something like that
yeah he did and he said he checked it
out and it [ __ ] hadn't already
checked out
that
yeah this did seem to be her handwriting
at least on her end of the [ __ ]
correspondence
although think about this
if you have two people writing [ __ ]
letters to each other what's the chances
that both of those [ __ ] both sides of
that correspondence ends up in the hand
of somebody's boss that's what i'm
saying
it doesn't usually happen that way
that's what i'm saying
but yeah
but i will say
i'm just going to say right now so
because marley mars says i honestly
don't think the story is true i don't
think it is either
aspects of it are true for sure which
i'm going to get into in a bit
but maybe the architecture aspect is
probably true yes it is uh some people
think this is based on true story yes
some people do
uh and oracle says the architecture is
pretty realistic uh yeah we'll get into
that in a bit
um
honestly i do think that gaston larue
was actually
um
maybe kind of a genius because he wrote
this story maybe because of his
background in
uh journalism
uh because he was a reporter he knew
what a true story he knew what a true
story sounded like and it's almost kind
of like i almost want to say it was like
a very early aspect of found footage
which like i said is not that crazy like
it's not that modern a concept if you
look back at a lot of victorian era
literature which i read a lot of
um
a lot of them were trying to make the
[ __ ] seem real
by doing like frame stories
where the person would be like i'm this
like distinguished scientist blah blah
blah or
adventure or whatever and i don't
usually believe in this kind of thing
but listen to this crazy [ __ ] that
happened to me and like they're like
telling a thing that happened to them so
there was like this kind of
trend
in
literature of this era to
make things seem like a true story just
like i said it's kind it's the same uh
thing behind found footage where it's
scarier if you think maybe it really
happened and i do think there was a
literary uh precedent for that i mean
like i said even in dracula which i
don't think bram stoker like tried to
make that seem like a true story but the
way he presented it he presented it as a
series of newspaper articles as a series
of diary entries things like that so he
kind of wanted to make it look like
a real story as much as possible at the
time so i think people think of the
concept of found footage or args or
something like that as being a modern
concept and it's totally not a lot of if
you go back and read a lot of like uh
horror fiction
gothic fiction
from the late 19th century early 20th
century a lot of it has
frame stories
that is somebody saying this is
absolutely true and you know i don't
usually believe in this kind of thing
but that's how it happened so there's a
lot of that going on
even certain aspects of lovecraft kind
of [ __ ] it was a little bit like and
he well he was very influenced by that
that's why it comes across like that
it's scarier if you think maybe this
[ __ ] really happened right i mean you
think that so even back then they had
figured that out so
what gaston larue did
in a way like the more i kind of like
looked into it i was like wow if this
dude was like this was like pretty
genius for the time even though other
people have been doing it too but he
took some [ __ ] that really did happen he
took a lot of stuff that really happened
which i'll get into in a minute
and he wove
a story about it through it and it
really seems like to this day people are
still kind of like wait did that [ __ ]
really happen you know what i mean
because he he was just so good at like
weaving it through there that it really
did seem like because he used enough
stuff
you know the place that he used the the
opera house to use that's a real place
you know some of the characters are
based on real people
and
he used real events
so much so so skillfully
that
there's
you know that there's still people that
think that maybe the whole [ __ ] really
happened so what jenny is saying she's
saying if this didn't happen
gaston was a beast
he could buy his ass off by taking [ __ ]
that really did happen and we even
narrated through it
that would make you [ __ ]
doubt
the action and i think that's what he
did okay well i think that's what she'll
show me later when we get to it yeah
because
i'm going to say that gaston had me
going reading it i was like
this matches up with what we know about
serial killers
and there's physical evidence left i
mean there's fascinating [ __ ] i got
fascinated by like the real aspects of
the story too because he did use a lot
of real [ __ ] right in this story so
there is that [ __ ] that eric does in
this tale
is the kind of things that serial
killers would do
yeah and they didn't have a term serial
killer no i mean like i said they had
the concept hh homes had been around
jack the ripper had been around um so
they
knew they didn't know the pattern they
didn't really know but they had seen it
psychology wasn't in the zeitgeist but
maybe a smart [ __ ] like gaston
could figure it out or put himself in
the shoes
of a person like that and marley mars
actually said this quite well said so in
a way gaston puts himself as gaston the
reporter yeah interesting and i think
smart for himself to be a character in
his own story which is what i've always
thought yeah i think that's exactly what
he did maybe he inserted himself
in the story in his
because he started out as a reporter and
then he went into like writing fiction
which i'll get into in a bit i thought
it was a mixture of fiction
it is in reality it is it is and that
maybe the phantom had actually existed
but we'll we'll see i mean i think
whether like okay
right now jenny hasn't disproven to me
but as it stands right now i think the
phantom was based on maybe some
maybe whether that person existed i'm
going to say right now nobody knows for
sure
okay there were some legends okay that
he based it on but there is no proof
that a person like that actually existed
and it might have just been like urban
legends exhibit a
as gaston was dying on his deathbed his
relatives like did that actually happen
he said yeah it did he at least he
believed it
according to or he wanted to like
continue or he was or he wanted to
continue the or he wanted to continue to
continue the story he's like i don't
want to like [ __ ] on everybody's
enjoyment of it he could have been
thinking that could be he didn't want to
disappoint people that they wanted to
believe it was real
but according to his relatives he said
no it happened i investigated it and
this is and i based the story based on
what i found
[Laughter]
some of the physical aspects some of the
physical evidence lines up with what
he's saying
yeah but like i said yeah i mean it
would be pretty easy write a [ __ ]
story around the physical evidence i
don't know well like i said it'd be very
easy for me to take a real event and
actually i'm working on a novel right
now yeah uh spoiler alert which is based
on a real
murder that happened
but i'm fictionalizing it but i'm using
a lot of the aspects and a lot of the
stuff that actually really happened in
real life but i'm fictionalizing it
so
jenny's [ __ ] jenny's [ __ ] jenny's
intelligent ass could see whatever the
[ __ ] she wants i was reading
when i was reading [ __ ] guests on the
road back in like 2017 2003 i'm reading
it and i'm going
i got a feeling this [ __ ] really
happened
and all the serial killer elements were
weaving into the story and i was like
if he made this up man he is way ahead
of his time something like this probably
did happen then
and he's he's writing this story based
upon what he found and this matches up
with what we know about serial killers
um including the way he looked
she hasn't gotten to that yet i know
what she's going to get at
in dominguez elementary school when i
was a kid down in california
i went to school with a kid
who kind of looked a little bit like
like
described in this book
but then jenny came out says no you know
what it looks even better and then she
talked about something else was like
yeah
yeah because i've seen pictures
of the disease that she was talking
about
and that fits close more closely
with what what is described in of the
opera
so even if this [ __ ] didn't happen
plausible it could have happened
it could have happened everything in the
story
everything we know about human behavior
everything we know about certain
diseases this [ __ ] could have happened
it's not it could have it didn't have
happened but it may have happened well
i'm not totally convinced but go ahead
go ahead zach says oh new book jenna
can't wait yeah it's going gonna be a
while i'm only on chapter seven
um but yeah i'm basing it on a real
murder but
i'm fictionalizing it and i'm doing like
some
i'm doing some fancy [ __ ] around the
edges we'll see how it turns out i'm
happy with it so far but i'm
it's it's kind of hard going i'm just
gonna say
uh so yeah so what are we talking about
okay so in the epilogue
uh you have gaston talking about
eric's life or at least what he could
piece together from it from the persian
um
according to the persian this is the
epilogue of the book now
um eric was the son of a
construction business owner he was born
deformed uh and we'll get into this
because some of the adaptations have
different reasons for his deformity
um but he was supposedly born deformed
and he ran away from where he was born
in normandy
and he worked in like fairs and
carnivals and stuff
and he got uh schooled in the arts of
the circus stage magic ventriloquy and
he was really good at that
across europe and asia and eventually uh
he was also an architectural genius
so he started building
palaces with like you know trick walls
and secret passages and [ __ ] like that
like elves and he kind of became known
for doing that
um so he gets hired by the sultan of
asia minor
and was uh part of some political
assassinations
he was really good at strangling people
that was kind of his
you know his his main thing that he did
so uh so yeah so he was kind of a
fighter the sultan be like hey go kill
this guy so he'd go strangle them and
that's how
that's how it went
now um this is kind of like brought up
in the book a little bit because
that was one of the ways that he would
kill people was like with ropes and
stuff and
he had this thing in the book
that was kind of like a what was it i
kind of feel like the way he described
it was like a pole with like a rope on
the end or something like a long
distance
strangling well that's easy mechanism
that was yeah that was a very common
tool
he was supposedly really good at that
you still use it today in capturing
animals
you use a long pipe like a pvc pipe
and you put a [ __ ]
rope down the end of it and then you
link it around so you have a
a [ __ ] noose
and then it it goes back into the pipe
so you put it over an animal's head and
pull it
now you have an animal on the end of a
on the end of a pipe
it's not to kill an animal though
it's to control an animal
wow yeah i've seen that just to capture
it i've seen this but you can kill
somebody with something like that sure
easily
but that that that's an old trick
so
yes that exists he's kind of like the
movie review that i'm putting up later
this week dario genta's trauma which has
a serial killer who uses
a mechanized garat
yeah to squinch people's heads off right
so you know people say well why would
you do that well if it's on the end of a
pole they can't run at you and attack
you you have them [ __ ] trapped at the
end of that damn pole
and you can just pull on it like in the
book like whenever anybody's like
running it eric they're always like put
your hand up like that so he can't like
get the [ __ ] thing around your neck
it's a way of capturing animals sure
animal control uses things like that
more modern versions of it
yeah so apparently according to the book
this is in the epilogue um
so he goes to france and he starts his
own construction business
at which point he was hired to work on
the uh palais garnier which is a real
opera house we'll get into that a little
bit where the fan of the opera set
and uh he was supposed to work on the
foundations and he's like ooh while i'm
down here i'm gonna build myself a
[ __ ] lair as you would yeah so he
builds like uh builds like all kind of
secret passages and [ __ ] tunnels and
all kind of [ __ ] yeah now in the book
from what i remember what they're
talking about is underneath the [ __ ]
underneath the [ __ ] theater house
it was a cave
and a cave had an underdog underground
lake
and that lake had a [ __ ]
island on it
which is there
okay well the island's not there yeah
well i thought the island was there no
it's not okay i'll get into that okay
she knows the detail
i thought that the island was actually
there but there's an underground lake
and on it evidently he built
kind of like a mansion
and um
i don't remember in the book exactly
what it has been so long but he was he
had
people bring stuff down there
and then he assembled it himself
like you would a wooden house
but it was evidently supposed to be a
pretty big wooden house
if i remember correctly i think might as
some of it might have been stone but if
i remember correctly from the book
mostly it was wood
i mean do you do you remember
i mean he had a lair down there that i
don't remember if they said it was wood
or stone but
i'm going by because like i said there
is
there is something under there but it's
not exactly like it was described in the
book okay
so
yeah that would be okay look
if that island isn't there
that would be a deal breaker for this
book
it's not it's not nope
okay
let's see jenny's [ __ ] me up it's not
an island there's not an island i'll get
into what that island
the audience
the book says there's an island
down there
underneath the opera house and they had
to get into a boat and row out
to this island and on that island was
eric's mansion
basically
and in that mansion we
basically was talking about he was
taught gaston was talking about
an hh home style torture palace
was basically what it was
with living quarters and
musical instruments and
you know an organ and and uh it was
supposed to be pretty nice but then it
had a bunch of torture
rooms
in there like a maze
that's that's what that's what's
described in the book from what i
remember
yeah yeah but that's not what it looks
like in real life but that's not what's
there in real life okay and see how it
is i've seen photos if that's not what's
down there if there isn't an island big
enough for that no then then he's making
this up well yeah that's what i've been
trying to tell okay that's not what it
looks like i've seen pictures of it it's
still there yeah it's not big enough
it's just it's not situated that the way
you're imagining it okay imagining okay
dj maniac says oh i just watched trauma
for the first time a few weeks ago
grizzly mo it was honestly i'm putting
the i'm putting the review up on
saturday or friday if you're a patron
i had not seen that movie for so long
and i was like oh i forgot how light
[ __ ] [ __ ] up because you know how
i'm like weird about beheading
but yeah squinching people's heads off
with a as tom savini called it a new
somatic
uh you know was uh that's pretty [ __ ]
up it made an impression i'm gonna say
so let's talk about
guest on larue the person
and where he got the inspiration for
this story
now larue um
so apparently i think oracle mentioned
this earlier
uh he was going to be a lawyer and he
actually had a large inheritance
but
he blew the inheritance gambling
so
don't gamble folks you're just pissing
pissing your [ __ ] money away but yeah
so he had to get a job
so
what he had to get a job he started
working as a reporter for a
newspaper called uh leco de peli or the
paris echo if you'd rather like i said i
took french for four years but my accent
is terrible
uh so when he worked at this newspaper
he basically he was like a courtroom
reporter
and he would also write about a
drama so i guess he would like go to
plays and see them and like review them
and whatnot so he did that
so he got to travel around a lot for his
job
um but after a while he was like well he
kind of wanted to more go in a fiction
direction
he was a big fan
of edgar allan poe
and also a big fan of sir arthur conan
doyle
so he wanted to write crime thrillers or
mysteries so that's what he first
started out doing so phantom of the
opera was actually not his first
fiction story he had actually written a
couple of uh ones prior to that
oh so tom's coming back yeah yeah
what happened to my drink i don't know
damn
i had to go get the water are you really
this drunk already
he puts his things down and he can't
although to be fair he does that when
he's sober too where are my glasses i
just had them
and then like he's like
[ __ ] searching all over and he can't
find him oh
i know it's it's hell getting old kids
it really is
i wanted him to come back because i
wanted him to like hear this because
he's like super excited about this story
but he keeps like wandering off
so i didn't want to like get too far
into it when he wasn't here
marley mars says oh man i got to get
going guys have a nice day everyone oh
well we're sorry to see you go but you
know
i know i understand everybody can hang
out with us for like four or five hours
like on a wednesday night
um
let me see yeah dog catchers use that
pole yeah i understand that paul that
he's talking about
and then camp guy also said the writer
probably saw a homeless dude living
under the theater and got this idea
honestly i think the idea for it
came from
many different sources which like i said
we'll get into okay so as okay you back
you want a drink um are you okay no i'm
good okay all right
so as i mentioned earlier and you
weren't here so i'm saying this like for
your benefit so he started out as a
courtroom reporter and also he critiqued
dramas so he would go to plays and like
write about them so he knew literature
well yeah yeah a new storytelling um so
cause like i said he had got like a huge
inheritance from his family but he blew
it gambling so he had to get a real job
so there was that
uh so he goes to paris and becomes a
writer now he was really really into
sir arthur conan doyle uh you know
obviously writer sherlock holmes and he
was really into edgar allan poe so he
wanted to like write some
thriller [ __ ] crime mystery that kind of
stuff
so in 1907 a couple years before he
wrote fan of the opera
he wrote a mystery story called the
mystery of the yellow room
and in 1908 i didn't actually i didn't
even know this listen as you guys
1908 he wrote a mystery
called the perfume of the lady in black
i was looking at his [ __ ] bio and i
was like holy [ __ ] i've seen a giallo
that was called that that's got to be
based on that [ __ ] it is
perfume of the lady in black written in
1908
was made into a movie
a bunch of times like five or six times
starting in 1914
that was i think the first movie
adaptation but they made an italian
giant movie
in 1974 because i've seen it
and i was just kind of like i didn't
even realize that that was based on one
of his [ __ ] books so that blew my
[ __ ] mind
it's you know it's just little things
like that so i was like holy crap i've
seen that movie that's a good movie i
even wrote like a big long thing about
it on my blog a long time ago
but yeah so he wrote that too
now uh 1909 as we mentioned earlier he
first started writing phantom of the
opera like as a serialized novel it came
out as a whole novel in 1910
now the setting of phantom of the opera
is an actual paris opera house it is
still there to this day it's beautiful
actually uh called the palais garnier
now this opera house
very baroque i love it
um
it was actually built at the behest of
napoleon
because he was born apart as in
bonaparte what happened
was that
he was going to the old opera house
which i'll get into in a bit
and some [ __ ] blew up
um because someone was trying to
assassinate him
so
he decided well when the old one
burned down he's like well we need a new
one that's like closer to the palace
so there's less space for me to like get
assassinated in now when you think of
opera house
these were the television sets
of the era
you know what i mean you had to go
somewhere to see a show
it was a physical location it was kind
of like the internet of the era
so you were like wow opera house that
was all they had
that was all they had you know
it was kind of like the internet of the
time
i don't mind i don't mind operas i
wouldn't mind i would have gone to see
operations
it was just a thing in the of the era
you know movie theaters nowadays you can
go and see like met operas like live
on the big screen you can still see that
nowadays they would show a opera and it
would be new
and [ __ ] from the best [ __ ]
directors and the best [ __ ]
performers and it's like you were seeing
some serious [ __ ] man
see see [ __ ] amadeus the movie
amadeus
amadeus is one of my favorite movies
that will explain that scene it's not
historically accurate no but much it
does encapsulate and capture that
[ __ ] scene yeah yeah
honestly like i got well
watching that movie
i mean it came out at 84. i think it won
best picture actually it's good fun move
fun movie i love that movie
but that was fun fact that was the first
movie that i bought
on dvd yeah and i was like oh my god
look at it i'm a dice yeah and amadeus
was a fun movie about [ __ ] opera
yeah how could opera be fun to see the
[ __ ] movie no it's not what you think
they were honestly they were mozart as a
person he's a rock star fascinating yeah
i've read a piece of [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] no he was actually he
wasn't like he was in the movie exactly
yeah
movie he was just annoying but i thought
but still kind of lovable
honestly i've read several biographies
of mozart he was kind of like that but
not
as exaggerated
um but mozart was a fascinating person
he was a fascinating person
it's so fascinating like i said that
i've read like several biographies those
honkies were [ __ ] genius back in
those days tell you what that
[ __ ] was sucking between him you
know what i mean do all kinds of [ __ ]
that a modern person couldn't do all
through brain power and [ __ ]
coordination playing [ __ ] whole
whole musical
sonatas backwards
and they could do [ __ ] but he could talk
backwards
you know he was
a prodigy they were sure yeah
and um
honestly
like between
of all the of all the biographies i've
read and i've read a lot my favorite
biographies i've ever read were of
mozart and the other favorite biography
i read was of caravaggio the painter who
was uh no also crazy who also murdered a
dude yeah so there was that
um
yeah one actually one of the best books
i've ever read of any kind was called m
the man who became caravaggio that book
was like [ __ ]
i just i love that book i love that book
it was so good you know another one was
the dude what was the dude that did this
[ __ ] michelangelo michelangelo
[ __ ] did some crazy [ __ ] too yeah
they were all kind of nuts back then he
knew how to get money out of the church
and uh he could draw he could paint
sistine chapel all that [ __ ] i love that
the church gave him money and he's just
like look i'm gonna paint like women
that look like uh hot dudes because
that's what he was in well he liked
[ __ ] he liked thick yeah he liked
thick
i understood well then back then yeah i
mean have you ever seen uh [ __ ] peter
paul reuben's paintings those are some
those were thick-ass ladies
yeah he was super into that they liked
big fine and like they were like thick
back then because people most people
were skinny so they were just trying to
but well if you were chunky that meant
that you didn't have to like work for a
living or you had money or yeah that's
what i mean you had money you'd have to
work for a living you had money you were
[ __ ] lucky you could afford like real
food yeah
and i think they did do some physical
training or they were hearkening back to
roman
statuary because the romans knew about
working out [ __ ] and uh you know
that was proven later on by by what's
his name
but oh [ __ ] dude the dude that came up
with [ __ ] olympia
and uh bodybuilding
what was his name [ __ ] uh man i
mentioned it many times that i've been
drinking
uh the romans knew about
getting bulk and [ __ ] working out and
guys guys you know guys later on
were homaging that like michelangelo
homage that
based on roman statuary that he was
seeing but it was true
it was true you could you can get big
like that
also i think my uh michelangelo might
have been gay i'm not entirely sure well
and they're kind of like wondering we're
caravaggio
i think like for my reading i think he
was probably bisexual uh he seemed uh
voracious and he would just like hit
anything yeah he didn't care if it was a
boy or a girl some people might be going
what are you talking about now this is
not the lgbt
no no no no not sure
um
when you go back and look at the old
the old statues there's a lot of homo
eroticism in there a big time and uh the
guys running the roman catholic church
you can tell what their tastes were
um
look at adam and chains it's a [ __ ]
great statue
and um
that's homoeroticism definitely
definitely
but
this is the way they were that's just
the way the word doesn't mean anything
they were [ __ ]
great artists
yeah i'm not bothered
like i said i'm i'm fascinated by the
i'm fascinated by that kind of [ __ ] and
it was centuries ago like i said look
into caravaggio he is a fascinating
fascinating person also a murderer yeah
um i actually wrote a an illustrated
novel or novel
novelette i guess
about him that's like a fictionalized
version of him
back in the day if you wanted to make a
[ __ ] ton of money selling art to the
roman catholic church
it is proven just by what they bought by
looking at what they bought
they bought things that were kind of
homoerotic
that's the way it was yeah yeah so and i
don't really know if they were all that
were they really that self-aware
or were they just like yeah i like that
and they just bought it without really
thinking about it too much or did they
i don't know it's i think they were
aware i mean they probably were because
there was they were writing about it at
the time you know the nipples are too
[ __ ] sick
you know the face on this is just too
goddamn sexy look at the buttocks yeah
they
[Laughter]
they were people
and uh
and in a lot of ways they were
you know uh well they had to be a lot
more in
in tune with their bodies than we are
nowadays because they didn't have the
luxury of being removed from their
bodies
like nowadays it's like everything
you're you know you can be very clean
and there we have like all of these
things that you know deodorants and
various things which they didn't really
have as much back then so i kind of feel
like people were more comfortable
with
the gross aspects of people's
physicality or their bodies
um you know peeing pooping whatever like
everybody like kind of watched everybody
do everything nobody really had any
privacy
to some extent in the era were talking
about
all of the money and power had been
had been [ __ ] centralized into the
church
if you were gay
you wanted to be in the church that's
where your protection would come
so
intelligent gay guys who had money
were working overtime to get into the
damn catholic church
this is all the way back to the [ __ ]
which is crazy if you think about it
nowadays yeah but
back then you're kind of like well i
don't want to get beaten to death in the
street right that's not the protection
that's where you're right you'd be
protected there
that's where the power is as long as you
kind of keep it on the dl like don't
talk about it out loud right because you
weren't supposed to be having sex in the
catholic church so you could be asexual
right but that's
if you ask me as a man
only a gay dude would want to go to the
church in that area in that era
everybody else was
going to be in the warrior class of the
merchant class or the ruling class
get entailed
but if you were gay and intelligent
you'd want to try to get in the church
especially
that especially if you had money i mean
if you had that uh if you had that
avenue open
then yeah you would probably do that
because like i said otherwise you'd be a
[ __ ] target you would get a big drug
you would want protection yep and uh you
could live a monastic life
and uh do some [ __ ] on the side as long
as you didn't talk about it long as you
talk about it and as long as i was on a
dl
then that's what they were talking about
i get it so when you got guys like
michelangelo coming up with these damn
statues of these hot dudes look like
they're getting ready to bust a nut
they're gonna be [ __ ] kind of like
tempted to buy these things look at the
[ __ ] statue adam and chains i don't
even think it was completed because they
said that [ __ ] was too
homoerotic oh
that's what they were working on it's
because michelangelo knew what these
dudes would buy
people haven't changed that much
people people have been people people
are evil hairless monkeys they have the
[ __ ] same urges that they always did
it was always about power and money and
status
and uh but that's not a bad thing a lot
of people are like oh that's terrible no
that's not that's the way he well i mean
you gotta like
just work it yeah that's the way humans
worry
you just kind of you gotta work your
system back in the day if you were gay
you had to be in a church
that's where you wanted to go
you get protection power and respect
and you can still have some [ __ ] on the
side you just couldn't like say anything
about it out loud
you had to be sneaky about it if they
did you know some of them may have been
monastic
uh yeah they probably were some of them
may have been lucky now i'm not going to
give in to my [ __ ] earthly pleasures
and [ __ ] yeah because i think well like
i said if people want to do that yeah
it's like that's fine i'm not [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about the church or
anything back in the day some of them
may have actually believed that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] lived by it sure because sure
some people did right yeah so i'm not
i'm not talking [ __ ] just that that's
where you wanted to be if you were gay
back in the day
yeah and well like i said i kind of feel
like a lot of artists back then
um
probably were like if not overtly gay
they probably had some like ambiguous
crypto sexuality crypto gay like i said
caravaggio i feel like was probably
bisexual by today's standards
um
but
i mean he kind of knew how to work the
system although still caravaggio was a
little bit of a bad boy he did get in
trouble a lot and a lot of stuff that he
got that got like um you know he got
stuff commissioned and then he would
paint it and they'd be like yeah no
we're not paying for that
we are layering in our sensibilities in
those days you may have have guys that
by today's standards would have been
considered to be kind of [ __ ] bi
um but maybe they hadn't acted on her
they weren't thinking along those lines
but that's kind of what they were if you
were in in a modern version looking at
them but that didn't happen with them
we are sometimes reading into what
they're doing
but i understand what they're doing you
know i mean i i you know it's just
they're like well i will do this and
that and this and that in the human body
and it's all in the glory of god
and it all depends upon how you want to
interpret
what it is that they're feeling
i don't have anything against
uh the old ways of doing things and
these old guys they were long gone
they were doing whatever it is that they
thought was right at the time
but they were
not modern people you know
well they didn't have access to the
information right they're not they're
not
they were low information people you
know i mean they didn't have social
media it wasn't their fault no no
no
i free
me tom
i forgive them all i forgive them all
thank you thomas i'm sure i'm sure they
have all they've all
they were
they were i absolve you yeah absolutely
they were intelligent people they were
good dudes they were from another era
trying to
make a living for themselves well i mean
that's all we can do we're all just like
imperfect yeah beings yeah we're just
trying to like [ __ ] cobble through
the best we can yeah without causing too
much
distress to others yeah hopefully it was
just beautiful art
money and architecture happening
yeah
i mean like i said i don't i don't talk
about it a lot on the show but i'm
really really into like yeah art history
i'm really into
all of those personalities
and uh
especially a lot of the classical era
artists like i said caravaggio is
probably my favorite but
because he's
uh a really interesting person
but um
you know but i love all of that stuff
going back go ahead and read some of the
uh comments every it's getting good in
there wait uh rebecca says 1908 my
grandparents were alive then
uh yeah a lot of people my grandparents
actually let me see
my grandparents were born my grandfather
was born in 1919
and my grandmother was born in 1929
uh they were both passed away now
but yeah so 1908 it wasn't really i was
a long time ago but it wasn't that long
ago
like
wait could you still be alive if you
were born in like how long ago was that
no i can't i can't math way longer no
you you're born in 1908 you're dead now
yeah but you'd still i mean you could
still conceivably have relatives that
were born then yeah because like i said
i'm only 49 and my grandparents were
only 10 years removed from that so
yeah you could totally still if you were
a little bit older than me you could
totally have grandparents i've got
pictures of my granddad in heidelberg
mississippi
in the 20s on the football team there so
you know
did he have those weird helmets yeah
like the leather helmet leather helmets
yeah yeah i remember that and you look
at him and there's nothing big about him
at all
nothing big
just look at a soccer player with a
helmet on a leather helmet
yeah like the the big like [ __ ]
that's a fairly recent that's all recent
yeah they were all
back in the day yeah
like i said that probably [ __ ] their
[ __ ] brains up a big time yeah back
in those days yeah zach says i can't go
a day without showering without my white
skin itching yeah because when i was
talking about
people not like uh
maybe washing every day maybe in the old
days sponge bath kind of deal i hope
they did but i kind of feel like
probably
depending on what class or classes back
then
i mean they were still pooping in a
bucket and tossing it out the window so
this is what we're talking about when it
came to like modern versions of
cleanliness
you're talking about the ancient romans
and mostly the rich people they had
running water and pools and [ __ ]
they went to the [ __ ] they're like
wash your ass baths
and uh they went and had them so doused
down with oil and [ __ ] scraped with
[ __ ] sweat scrapers to get the oil
off them they were a lot cleaner zach
says no i meant whole skin lmao and so
because i said was because he said wild
yeah and i said white
whole skin old skin
roman middle class and upper class were
modern versions of clean
but i don't think many of the other ones
were
kind of dirty
although if i got a time machine i'm
going to go back in time and stand next
to some ancient romans i'm going to
spell them
yeah we'll see are they stinky
they wouldn't were they maybe not maybe
not they wore fragrance they had
themselves oiled
and scraped
yeah there was like the scraping there
was great and they also had them tweezed
and shaved so they didn't have body hair
i mean the upper class did yeah but she
would hire somebody they could do that
[ __ ] yeah that'd be nice yeah or the
opportunities
middle-class people i wouldn't wish that
on anybody or middle-class people that
wanted to appear upper class you know if
you have money then you go to
even if i was paying i don't feel good
about everything worked on paying money
to have somebody pluck all my hairs out
well you had a lot of extra time
they would sat around and just [ __ ]
i don't think i could really i don't
know i i just can't really
i don't know i have a hard time it's
just kind of like you know how some
people will sometimes like hire a person
that'll like clean their house or
whatever yeah
i have a hard time dealing with that you
do okay you get you know the drink i'm
like what is it like like i'm perfectly
capable of cleaning up after myself i'm
just too lazy to do it evidently so i'm
gonna hire somebody to do it i would
like feel really bad about like i don't
know maybe that's just my issue i would
feel really bad about like hiring
somebody to like
do some
do some [ __ ] that i wouldn't like to do
for another person let's say that like
that i don't want to like pluck other
people's hairs out i don't want to clean
other people's toilets
i know people do it but
i don't feel good having to pay somebody
like doing like to do that for me
because i was like
i don't know i can do that for myself
i'm a capable adult so yeah all right so
as we were saying so the setting of
phantom of the opera
is an actual paris opera house palais
garnier which is still there you can
still visit it to this day it's a it's
gorgeous
now this was uh as i mentioned earlier
built at the behest of emperor napoleon
napoleon bonaparte um after he was uh
almost blown up by italian anarchist
assassins
on his way to the opera like there was a
big explosion and he was kind of like
yeah let's uh build an opera house there
was an opera house but it burned down
i'll get into that later
um but we need one closer to the palace
so we have like less distance to go in
which we can be blown up so
we're gonna have like this other opera
house built
now uh
so
gas on larue had apparently heard rumors
some of these are based in fact and some
maybe not so much
he had heard rumors uh that around the
time that the opera house was finished
during and this is one of the rumors
that was going around
during act one of an opera called hele
uh so the act one had just finished
and then there was a fire in the roof of
the opera
and it melted through a wire which was
holding a counterweight for the
chandelier
and cause the chandelier to crash
down through the ceiling
and kill a bunch or kill one person and
injure a bunch of people
now as i mentioned earlier
this was an actual thing that happened
and i saw all the french language
newspaper uh [ __ ] from the time
this actually happened on may 20th
1896.
one of the chandeliers it wasn't
actually the chandelier that came down
because i know in the play it was the
chandelier that came down because that's
a lot more exciting
it wasn't actually the chandelier what
happened was that one of the chandeliers
counterweights
broke free
a spark from
uh the electric lighting
uh like kind of popped off and fell onto
the wire that was holding the chandelier
in place and melted it
so
the counterweight
actually uh
fell through the ceiling
and into the auditorium
and killed a woman who was a concierge
at the opera house named madame chomet
now the actual falling of the
counterweight actually crashed when it
fell it crashed into a circuit breaker
and started a fire
so that did actually happen i saw the
newspaper reports and everything um
may 21st i love this
but i mean this is [ __ ] up but i love
it
may 21st 1896 issue of uh limata which
is the french newspaper
uh guests on larue actually at the time
uh was moonlighting at this paper when
this uh article was published fun fact
the headline read
500 kilos on a concierge's head
and i was like
classy keep it classy french newspapers
from the 19th century
um
you know it killed a person that's
that's not funny but okay
uh in reality the counterweight actually
weighed less than 10 kilos so it wasn't
500 kilos we're getting excited they
they went way overboard with that
a newspaper i actually read the article
like an english translation of the
article
and it actually said that the woman's
skull was completely crushed
and quote her right hand and leg torn
apart so that's pretty [ __ ] up so it
wasn't actually the chandelier that fell
but it was a counterweight so that was a
real thing that happened at this opera
house that
uh you know that gaston larue like based
the [ __ ] on
now the details about the palais garnier
and the rumors surrounding it um
are pretty kind of like
intertwined in the novel let's say that
so the underground
lake let's call it lake with bunny
rabbit ears as eddie azar says
um it does there is
something under there like that it's not
a lake though i'm not gonna go so far as
that
um
what it is under there they still use
the [ __ ] it's still there um i think you
can do a tour of it although i'm not
entirely sure like what the
availability of the tour is
but i have seen people recently that
said they did a tour than they saw the
ship
um
they still use it for training uh
firefighters like teaching them how to
like swim in like dark conditions and
stuff so they do like use that for that
but strictly speaking
it's not
a lake
what happened was that
when the concrete foundations of the
opera house were poured in january of
1862.
the people that were working on
the project
found that the water table was much
higher than they had anticipated uh
might have been some like seepage from
the sun i think uh the river
so what they did was they were like okay
well they installed a whole bunch of
like wells and pumps and ship like to
get the water out of there because they
were trying to like install the sub
basements like the substructure of the
opera house
but however many pumps they put in there
uh the water just would not go away it
just persisted
so what they decided to do the original
architect uh whose name was charles
garnier
decided okay well what we're going to do
we're going to do a double foundation
and in this foundation we're going to do
like a watercourse and a big cistern
um which if we ever have a fire in the
opera house then that will serve as a
ready water supply because there's
already water under there
so basically what they did and as i said
you you can see pictures of it if you
just do um do a google search on pele
garnier
underground vault or cistern or
underground lake or whatever and you'll
see like tons of pictures of it
so what they did was they just built a
cistern
around like to keep the moisture away
from the
opera house the upper levels
and to have some water down there in
case there was a fire so if you see
pictures of it it's basically just like
water with like cement
like a cement arch over it is what it
looks like so it's not a real
underground no no cave no
how big are we talking about um i'm not
entirely sure there's a lot of like
underground because honestly the the
opera house has
several levels like below ground
but it was just this one that they built
like water kept seeping into it
um and naturally just from the river
nearby and they were just kind of like
well we can't fix it so we just have to
like accommodate it so
what they did was they just built a
cistern so the water wouldn't come up
and like contaminate the upper levels so
it's basically like a water cistern is
what it is so it's kind of like if you
see pictures of it it's just like a
cement
or you know cement blocks and it's just
kind of like arches
like that and then it's just like like
water underneath like i said do a google
search on palais
p-a-l-a-i-s
garnier like like the hair product
no
p-a-l-a-i-s just one out
i s
garnier
carne opera house france
okay and then what and then put like
underground lake or cistern or whatever
underground lake because a lot of people
ask about that because the phantom of
the upper okay and you can see pictures
of it okay
do you see what it looks like yeah yeah
yeah it actually is bigger than i
thought it was gonna yeah it's pretty
it's pretty big yeah
i mean it has like a lot of underground
i was going to do picture but i forgot
but yeah
that's okay
it looks like that it looks like that
yeah
although that's artificial roofs and
walls i wonder what it looked like back
in the day
no that's what it looked like back in
the day that's what they built yeah
because of the water seeping in
the original architecture so during the
time
during the time of the phantom it would
look like that
yes yes
so there's no
i'm looking at it now
there's no lake there'll be no it's like
i said it's not a lake really a lake
with a
no like i said they just built it like
that because when they were first i'm
building it fantastic look at that yeah
it's it's pretty cool looking yeah
when they were first building it they
couldn't get rid of the water that was
seeping in from the river okay so they
accommodated it by building like
essentially a cistern so there isn't in
the lower level an island really no
it's not a natural i mean the water
seeping in is natural it's highly but it
was a it was something that they came up
with to like a comedy
yeah they put catfish well no they
didn't put catfish in it there's catfish
in it because it was seepage from the
river yeah apparently there's like a
famous catfish that lives in there like
the staff still feed i don't know if
that's true or not but that's what i
heard
okay so
i'm looking at it and and it
it's big but it's not big enough to have
an island on or a [ __ ]
a mansion on that island
it's not that big yeah it is there and
like i said that was there from when
they built it okay from when they built
it okay um so that kind of shoots holes
in the whole phantom of the opera story
because you're supposed to be living
on an island
and on that island a damn mansion
that's not big enough
no probably not
it's also not
ne it's not natural at all no
at all no
it was just something it was a problem
that they encountered when they were
digging the foundation and pouring the
foundation for the opera house and they
were kind of like holy [ __ ] we can't get
rid of this water okay they kept
installing pumps and they were trying to
like pump the water out and they
couldn't do it so he was like well why
don't we just like make
essentially like a water reservoir
you're right in the lower levels
um
so just so don't pump it out just leave
it so that's what they did well that's a
big [ __ ] strike against this story
because
the story describes an underground
lake
with an island and a mansion on it
that he built that mansion on that lake
that's not big enough
no
no well that's what i'm telling you
right that's what i don't like want to
show on your birthday if there was an
eric he wouldn't have been living down
there
probably not i mean the opera house and
it's under carriage yeah is big enough
for somebody to live down there without
anybody being aware of it but
now
you wouldn't be living in like mansion
conditions no
no no i mean because in the book it says
you had to have a boat
to [ __ ]
paddle your ass out to the [ __ ]
to the [ __ ]
island and then get off and walk
up into the mansion
and that people were buried along
outside the mansion
because he said the [ __ ] he un that
he said that he found some buried bodies
on that island okay we'll get into that
in a little bit but you know and i don't
see any island no there's not an island
no like i said it's just
it's cistern that's it and it looks like
something out of ancient rome yeah
that's a lot of those they were just
accommodating yeah the natural
conditions right because they couldn't
get rid of the seepage from the river
so that's what they did they said well
we'll just leave it there but we're
going to like you know close it in all
right
now uh
also it should be said
that the rooms that gas on the roof
claim to be the phantom's lair
underground uh there are actually some
technical rooms for the opera house that
still occupy those rooms underground
there are actually the opera house i
believe
has four or five levels
underground
you know what i mean so like the lake is
like way under there but there's other
floors uh other than that
uh there are secret passages
um
which are mentioned in the novel there
are two of them
uh the first one starts five levels down
uh and it goes down to
like basically way down the basement
level
a couple like four or five levels down
below the basement and if there's like a
ladder and you can go up to the fourth
floor of the opera house
uh that's one of the tunnels the other
secret tunnel
um is a rainwater evacuation chute so
there's that as well
now uh adding to the mystery surrounding
this underground lake or cistern if
you'd rather
was the fact that in 1871 before the
opera house was finished
because it wasn't actually um
inaugurated until 1875 i think
um
it was used before it was done it was
used by the paris commune which was a
revolutionary government uh seized power
in paris for a few months in spring of
1871
uh and they stored some like food and
ammunition in there
uh this group took over paris with the
national guard this was after the
franco-prussian war and they set up a
base camp in this unfinished building
uh because it was close to uh the place
vandam
where the guard was fighting the french
army
so after they got kicked out after the
few months they were in there uh then
they started like working on the
building again
now interestingly this is another thing
that i think was very influential on
guests on larue
in 1907 a couple years before he wrote
phantom of the opera
they buried a time capsule
um in the cellar of the opera house
which like i said had been finished it
was uh actually inaugurated in 1875.
but they buried a time capsule in there
in 1907
and it was kind of like i've seen
pictures of it it's like it looks like a
hat box but i think it was made of lead
or some lead line material
what they did was they made a bunch of
phonograph or you know record
recordings of opera singers
of the time
you know in 1907
and they buried and they put them in
this thing and they buried them
underneath the opera house
so it was kind of like a big deal at the
time in paris like we're making these 24
records of opera singers that are
popular
in 1907 and were burying a time capsule
so they did that like underneath the uh
the opera house now these records
do exist because they found them or they
knew they were there but they unearthed
them
in late 2007 and then presented them to
the public in 2008 so it's kind of like
like i said it's like a hat box but it's
made of lead and there was like 24
records in there it's like wax yeah you
know before they had final
so and it was all the popular opera
singers of the period
were on those records which is actually
like pretty cool like i went down a
whole rabbit hole about that but i
didn't want to like go too much on this
show because but i was like really
interested
i thought that was cool but yeah
now
when this
uh
when these records were first buried
so the legend goes
the legend says
uh and gasson larue said
that when they were burying
this time capsule
that they also found a body
of a disfigured architect named eric
um who was found while they were burying
the records okay
now
let's see what happens this is not
uh there is no like
source that corroborates this
definitively
um
so there's that
so most people think nowadays that's
probably not true that's probably not
true but because of the big hoopla
about these records being buried
around the time that gaston was writing
this or a couple years before
that he might have used that as like
inspiration oh while they were digging
for to bury the records they found this
body okay and it had a ring on it he
said this wind
when did gaston say this
well no he said this um he said this
during
so when did he say this
i can't remember actually i can't
remember okay i would like i would like
to figure out what this happened so
gaston is saying that they found a body
of an architect
while they were digging to bury this
time capsule
okay they're but no other okay no
contemporary neosource
says that they found a body they're
burying the time capsule in 1906. 1987.
1907.
uh okay so but no contemporaneous source
says oh we found a body
that's samsung nothing said that that's
him saying
that 1907. yes
so where's this body
that's what i'm saying yeah
now i will say
it's not crazy what he's saying because
not necessarily where is this supposed
to be buried
underneath the opera house where there's
no island there
well yeah it's just a cistern yeah
that's what i'm telling you okay okay
but um but yeah
now i will say i will say
that
even though he said he might have been
inspired by the fact now they did find i
don't know if it was when they were i
don't think it was when they were
digging for the to bury the um time
capsule
but they did find some bodies under
there
nothing like what he described
but the bodies they found under there
maybe they thought were probably
remember when i said that like the paris
commune was occupying that like you know
to store food and supplies and stuff
um
they thought that maybe they were using
that briefly as a uh like a prison so
they were like putting people in there
and maybe they were dying and so they
found a couple skeletons in there i
think
so
there was like a precedent for finding
skeletons in there but it wasn't like
because he said later that it's like oh
they found a skeleton that had the gold
ring on there yeah the gold rang that
christine supposedly like gave back to
him and blah blah blah so it was kind of
like matching up with his story you know
what i'm saying yeah but
i'm not saying that they didn't find
bodies under there i'm just saying that
it didn't have anything to do with like
the architect story because that's a
whole different thing okay that's all
everything and we'll get into that
and uh as i mentioned earlier
about the hh homes thing
because you because you were saying like
you thought hh homes was later or like
after this
but it wasn't it it did actually happen
before this hh homes was actually before
this yeah he was executed in 1896. okay
what this means people is that the
hhomes case which is like one of the
first really big serial killer case
cases in the west
hh combs was kind of like a blueprint
for a serial killer
so
we can surmise that possibly
gaston
knew about serial killers based upon hh
homes
i think that's pretty likely h.h holmes
was i mean
h.h holm's story is very similar to the
to fan of the opera story
so
there's a possibility based on what
jenny is saying is that
phantom of the opera may have been
partially
inspired by
h.h combs which like i said i don't
think there's any direct evidence of
that but it means it was in the
zeitgeist sure
the fact that h.h holmes
he was executed in 1896. his murder
castle
you know even though it was
exaggerated
um was big deal in the media back in the
day and i feel like gaston larue even
though he was in france uh he totally
would have read about that he knew about
it i'm not saying that he did i'm just
saying that it's
it was in the zeitgeist it's possible
sure
and he might have got inspired by that
okay
because he did like i said he took his
inspiration from a lot of real [ __ ] that
happened
he used a real opera house
um as we'll mention he used like some
real people uh and changed their names
he did that kind of [ __ ] so i kind of
feel like he did a very skillful weave
of real [ __ ] and fictional [ __ ]
to a point where now nobody can like
tease apart the just the difference you
know gaston was a [ __ ] intelligent
guy
he was a news reporter
and a [ __ ] a writer
so he could have been inspired
by
um
h.h holmes that would be enough to
inspire him
to weave a tail like this
yeah but i wasn't sure i wasn't sure if
he knew about it well like i said
the thing about it like i'm a writer i
guess so it's just and i've and i've
read a lot of things that were based on
real things but were like fictionalized
so
writers like use real [ __ ]
in their fiction all the time
it's just that sometimes you try to like
mask it a little bit
yeah sometimes not like i said the novel
i'm working on now is pretty
transparently based on a real murder but
i'm fictionalizing it to a point where
i'm taking it off in a different
direction but
i kind of feel like that's probably what
happened here because like i said they
weren't dumb they were still doing that
[ __ ] back then see the thing right now
that's gotten me
kind of doubt in the story
is based on jenny's research he's shown
me the photographs of that underground
cave
it is a man-made
style cave it's [ __ ] it's a cistern
a roman style sister i mean the building
of the opera house is very well
documented and that's not what's
described in the book no what's
described in the book is a naturally
occurring cave
with a lake in it
with a
island that is big enough to put
basically a mansion on it
that's not what i saw
in the photographs now well like i said
it's not a naturally occurring feature
no it's not a natural feature and like i
said
the opera house was finished or was uh
you know
opened in 1875
uh you know many years before this book
so this is making me believe that the
[ __ ] story is
[ __ ] yeah
but very cool [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying but he was very good at like
weaving real [ __ ] with fictional [ __ ]
yeah
like i said to a point where people
nowadays are still kind of like wait did
that really happen some of it really
happened it just goes to show you how
smart the ancients were
there
well see i don't i don't like have any
like i said i read a lot of i'm into
horror fiction i really like victorian
horror fiction
if you read some of their [ __ ]
they totally understood the concept of
quote unquote found footage they totally
understood that concept i don't they
wouldn't call it that obviously they
also knew they also knew what suspension
of disbelief was yeah
yeah that's why they weren't stupid no
they wanted particularly their ghost
stories all that kind of stuff they
wanted verisimilitude they wanted this
to be scary and they understood
if you think it's real
then it's going to be scarier to you
same as like creepypastas nowadays same
thing yeah so they were kind of like
we're going to frame this
as though it really happened
i have read multiple stories from this
time period and earlier
that had the same conceit
right so they absolutely knew what they
were doing and we're talking about over
a hundred years ago they absolutely knew
what they were doing yeah so it's uh i
kind of feel like it's a little
please don't it's a little it
it's really not a thing it's like they
really knew what they were doing back
then
if you read the [ __ ] from back then they
knew what they were doing yeah they knew
that that
we have to like make this seem as real
as possible to make it seem scarier
right
and that's how they framed a lot of the
stuff and if a dude over 100 years ago
could do it to you
and that means a guy from 2000 years ago
could do it to you
well yeah i've read i i've read roman
stuff
that is looking awesome and they're
probably [ __ ] with me a lot of that
[ __ ] and then it's just
people people that's what i'm saying you
can't you can't really take it at face
value
see this is why i'm going to be realized
i don't think they work i'm a big
advocate of
uh
evidence i don't really give a [ __ ] what
people say people can say
whatever they want yeah
that doesn't matter to me and it's
usually a lie
especially a western writer sure because
this is all coming from our point of
view with our literary [ __ ]
background
and our literary traditions so they know
how to [ __ ] with you
mary says do the brothers grim
that's actually a good idea yeah yeah
yeah there's been a lot of cool [ __ ] i'm
gonna write that down okay
because i'm savage [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] savage [ __ ] too
cutting people's feet off to fit the
[ __ ] shoe and all that kind of
cinderella cinderella yeah
honestly i always preferred the brothers
grim version yeah yeah i mean
better i mean yeah they they were a lot
more messed up which obviously i'm going
to be more into that
but yeah so let's talk about okay
so it's still very much up in the air
whether the character of eric
i kind of feel like in the musical
they don't name him
but in the book he's called eric with a
k yeah
in the musical they don't say what his
name is but his name is eric yeah
so there's uh still kind of like a
debate whether this character was based
on a real person or not
uh because i kind of feel like maybe
aspects of his personality maybe based
on like a legend maybe not necessarily a
real person but nobody knows
now it could be
that the um because like you said he's
uh portrayed as like a musical genius
because in the book he
composes his own operas and he has all
this he plays piano and all this stuff
so um the genius side of his personality
might have been inspired
by
uh several different composers uh
including like franz liszt maybe
an italian composer
called uh geokino rossini who was called
the angel of music which he's referred
to in the book
or eric saty which
had similar
upbringings i guess
so there's that
uh so in the original novel there aren't
really a lot of details as i mentioned
earlier um you know that go into like
his past
so the novel says that eric uh has been
to multiple countries france russia
persia northern vietnam
and he was like uh maybe like a circus
freak or it trained in like certain
circus arts like
stage magic ventriloquy
stuff like that
um
many of the stories say that he
was uh
born
deformed
and that his mother was so horrified by
his deformity that she would never
kiss him or she would never like uh you
know
interact with him in any way
uh his dad who was supposedly a master
mason never saw him
now
so there's that so like i said it's kind
of like
the [ __ ] that comes out about him in the
book
is all from the point of view of the
persian
who's also known as the deroga now
deroga
okay according to the story the
the persian in the book
was supposedly this guy
who
after
eric supposedly was working for
uh
you know the show whatever and he was
like supposed to like assassinate people
and then but like he knew too much
so the persian was actually supposed to
assassinate him
but felt bad for him so didn't so they
like went on the run kind of together
so he's kind of one the one that's
telling his story so there's that
but
um
yeah so
a lot of the story like comes from pam
right
now
after like um
[Music]
eric comes to paris
um
[Music]
there's some kind of point like the
persian says some [ __ ] that's like his
background oh he was born in like rua
which is in uh
in rural france
and
there's one thing too that it's not
brought up a lot in
a lot of the adaptations
is that in the novel
um
the phantom like or eric like talks to
about himself like in the third person
and i kind of feel like they don't
really do that in the movies but he does
that in the book though
now
i will say though that some of the
i'm let me tell okay so let me talk
about like some of the adaptations at
this point
in the book
it's pretty
clearly stated that eric
is
was deformed at birth right he was born
like that his mother couldn't stand to
look at him she wouldn't kiss him maybe
we should talk about it yeah we're
talking about that right now good
um now some of the later adaptations
have him
deformed as an adult
like somebody threw acid in his face or
you know he burned to death burned or
something like that
but in the book
uh the implication is
that he was born that way with that
deformity
now in the original novel
this is how he's described and this is
not always how he turns out in the
adaptations
but in the original novel
he's described as
corpse-like
as i said he looks like
everybody that sees him originally they
think he's a ghost at first
they see him and they he looks like a
skeleton like he always has nice clothes
on like evening clothes like a tuxedo
i'm imagining
but he looks like a skeleton and his
face looks like a skull
he doesn't have a nose
his eyes are like so sunk into his face
that he look that they look like sockets
but they kind of like glow in the dark
like a cat's eyes like yellow
um his skin is also
uh what they got look he says like nasty
quote-unquote nasty yellow yeah so his
skin is like uh that he only has like he
doesn't have that much hair like he's
almost partially bald i kind of felt
like
the way he described it i was imagining
like the head of like riffraff from
rocky where he was like bald at the top
but it was like long at this at the
sides that's kind of like what i was
imagining he said it has so much hair
but it's mostly bald and it's like you
know kind of like [ __ ] wisps of brown
hair behind his ears and on his forehead
a little bit
um they don't really describe his mouth
all that much like i know that the lawn
chainy one like his teeth are kind of
like [ __ ] up but like i said the lon
chaney look
that's the most accurate to the book
that's pretty much how he was described
although not as skeletal
but yeah
um his mouth christine describes it as a
dead mouth
and uh so something's [ __ ] wrong with
his mouth
uh and like i said he's very very thin
and his hands are like boney like
skeletal
and
uh feel death-like or smell death-like
like so he stunk apparently um like a
corpse
so there's that
as i mentioned
this is what jenny's talking about
that's congenital syphilis
which
yeah maybe
but there's there's even better photos
like we'll get into that a little bit
but yeah
i want to say too that yeah so in the
original book
we're talking about like all the
adaptations here's another photo
oh [ __ ]
is it gross yeah trigger warning
yeah so see that's what they're talking
about
yeah we'll get into that in a bit
because i uncovered some [ __ ] about that
too yeah
because i was interested and apparently
i wasn't the only person because i found
another blog post but they were like
what what disease would have made him
look like that but yeah he looked like
um
he's described many times as looking
like a walking corpse essentially or
like a walking skeleton that's what he
looked like
and in the novel
he shows up at the masquerade ball
looking like the red death from the
edgar allan poe story mask of the red
death which like i said was essentially
like a skeletal
yeah like a skeletal figure yeah
so he looked like and
most of the people in the novel that
like saw him early
they said he looked like a quote-unquote
death head like he looked like a skull
his face looked like a skull he didn't
have a nose he was also described with
no nose there you go yeah he looked like
yeah like he didn't know
no nose
that's what they're talking like he
looked like that
in the original book yeah like i said
that's that's what he looked like
everybody said he looked like a like a
skull like a skeleton
um and he even says
uh
to christine at one point in the novel
um they look like a corpse built up with
death from head to foot
like he'd be going through all these
photos he looked like a skeleton i was
going through all these photos of these
syphilis people most of them don't have
noses
that's what they're talking about
and
yeah
and the thing about it was that when i
mean if he's based on a real person or
not which like i said is you know is
still a matter of much debate yeah
um
that he had been in
uh freak shows carnival freak shows and
he was displayed as a living corpse or
le morphibon
the living dead
um
that's what that means
um
[Music]
for many years
so he looked like
a corpse but he was like walking around
and that looks very much as how he's
described in the book i'm looking at
these ships looking like a corpse i'm
looking at these people that were born
with syphilis they're born with syphilis
they didn't catch it they were born with
it
they look like eddie
from [ __ ] iron maiden most of them
don't have noses
that's what they're talking about
yeah i kind of thought this might have
been [ __ ] plausible
well it could be i mean because syphilis
was a lot more
commonplace back then so it's very
possible
that they could have seen people
that had uh tertiary syphilis yeah back
in the old days maybe in a freak show or
maybe like yeah you know in photos like
that they don't have noses because it
would have been uh kind of a source of
fascination and curiosity for people
back in that era yeah so
it could have been that he just like
based it on like some [ __ ] that he saw
in a photo or in like a freak show or
something right he's so because if you
had that yeah
um like i said and that's like tertiary
syphilis
you can have syphilis for a while
without it having any really drastic
consequences but once it goes into the
tertiary phase yeah um your nose is
gonna fall off all kind of lake badge
that's going to happen
no nose yeah
see i mean that yeah
i can if you and i'll get into that
because i did find like a blog post but
yeah
uh let me talk about too this is i don't
know why i found this real like this is
still the worst one if you ask me
that's [ __ ]
horrible oh yeah i've seen that picture
yeah pretty famous can you imagine like
looking like that when you're right no
nose and the [ __ ] skull like teeth
born with syphilis
i've seen one that's worse than that but
i can't find it right now
it's a it was somebody born with
syphilis and
they look like eddie from iron maiden
look like a living corpse
but i can't find it here
which like i said if
eric from fan of the opera was based on
a real person which he might have been
that's what they're talking about i mean
even the look of him might have just
been based on somebody that gasland
really saw at some point because like i
said the victorians were real into
freak shows yeah gotta say um they were
real into like that morbid [ __ ] which
like no judgment i am too but you know
here's what they were into that so
a black and white photo it should be a
color photo
imagine
oh man
imagine that
[ __ ]
i'd wear a mask too
but yeah
i mean it does so it so it's entirely
possible that even if this wasn't based
on a real person entirely yeah that it
could have been based on somebody that
he saw at one point because
yeah syphilis was fairly widespread at
the time like i said we're gonna get
into that
and uh yeah that would absolutely could
absolutely make your face look like
you look like a skull
sure
so okay now in the novel this was kind
of interesting to me i don't know why
in the novel um
eric was always wearing like a black
cloak
and a soft black felt hat
now he had a black mask which covered
his whole
face
i feel like later they did the white
mask thing
uh and a lot of times they would do like
half mask or like just the domino mask
which is just like over your eyes
but in the book that wasn't he was it
was a whole
face and it was black
everything was black like the cloak and
everything
so i kind of feel like later
they did a thing where they put him in
like a top hat and like the domino mask
like i said
and a cape
like an opera cape
which
not so much uh in the book like i said
it was just like a cloak
whole face mask like so it's kind of
like a fedora
more than a top hat yeah
um but yeah so there was that so i kind
of feel like uh andrew lloyd webber's
version introduced the half mask now
they only did that for practical reasons
because they're like well
you can't really like it's a stage
production you can't really see the
person's face you can't really see their
expressions you can't really hear them
sing as much if their whole face is
covered by a mask so that was the
solution they came up with we're gonna
[ __ ] up half his face and do this half
mask but in the earlier in the original
novel it was his whole face was [ __ ]
up
and
it was a whole face mask but i
understand like why they did that for
just for like i said practical reasons
now i will say though that it wasn't
just the movies
that
gave the impression because i will note
that when the
serialized story came out as a book in
1910 the original cover of it
the ls the illustration on there
had
just a domino mask
like just over the eyes
and had a top hat and kind of like a
cape-like situation so it might have
been just like the illustrators
[ __ ] that that kind of happened there
now there were uh like a bunch of movies
uh varying the deformities obviously
in the
1943 adaptation
um he's kind of like disfigured when he
gets acid thrown in his face because
like i said
even though in the original novel it's
implied that the deformities are
congenital
as in he had them from birth
uh in some of the later adaptations he
got them as an adult
usually from acid being thrown in his
face or from being uh in a fire
at some point there's also a phantom of
the paradise which we reviewed from 1974
and at that point
uh in that movie he got [ __ ] up
because he got caught in a record press
yeah yeah yeah so there was that but
it's the same story but you know what i
mean
um and i mentioned earlier that there
was a version with robert england i
think they came in 89
and he kind of had a thing where he
would just stitch together
like he would kill people and then he'd
stitch their skin together like kind of
like leather face and he would like put
that on his face
but then like his face would get more
[ __ ] up like as time went on so there
was that too that was a more horror
version
um
so yeah so like i said the half mask i
can see how they
came up with that but
it wasn't
like the original novel people in the
comments are going oh okay we see we're
talking about now yeah
yeah that's what [ __ ] gaston is
talking about
and i kind of feel like people back then
probably would have been more familiar
with it it probably would have been more
common
because nowadays you're being shielded
from all this yeah you don't really see
well it's not as common as it used to be
one uh you know there are cures for it
there are various other things that
ensure that you don't see people that
look like that yeah
back then
um
not so much it would have been more
common you'd have seen them in freak
shows and you would have seen them in
freak shows and victorians were really
into that [ __ ] yeah and they wouldn't
have known one thing from another
they wouldn't have really known if you
would have seen somebody who just [ __ ]
up like some off of a [ __ ] iron man
album cover you wouldn't have said well
that's syphilis you wouldn't have known
what it was
because it was always different
yeah it doesn't manifest the same yeah
they'd be like what the [ __ ] is that
right um
but it does do that often enough right
for me to think now we have categorized
it but back in those days they wouldn't
have known what it was yeah
i mean yeah
but yeah so i but like i said i think
most people are probably familiar with
the andrew lloyd webber version which
you know started in 1986 which had the
half mask now his face is [ __ ] up and
his hair [ __ ] like he pulls the mask
off and his
face is like super [ __ ] up and his
hair is kind of [ __ ] up but i mean in
the original novel his whole face was
and in fact his whole body was [ __ ] up
yeah because like i said he looked
like a skeleton or like a living corpse
like his whole body he looked like a
skeleton so it wasn't just his face but
his whole face was [ __ ] up he looked
like a skull
um but i understand why they did that
for later [ __ ] and also
like i said they made it more into like
a romance which is
kind of weird but okay that's not what
it was
it wasn't but like i said they did what
they did that with dracula too yeah uh
which was equally [ __ ] up well
maybe not equally [ __ ] up because at
least dracula in the story wasn't
supposed to be like a romantic yeah
character in phantom of the opera
there was like some
i don't want to call it a love story
because it wasn't it was like one-sided
but there was some stalker situation
going on right and
i feel like they romanticized that in
later iterations
but
i don't think it was intended as that
from the jump i don't think
i kind of feel like reading the original
novel again
which i did over the last couple days
i feel like raul was supposed to be the
hero even though he's a total dick
but i kind of feel like he's supposed to
be the hero the phantom is not he's
supposed to be like the tragic he's a
tragic villain
or tragic i don't want to even want to
say anti-hero he's a tragic villain you
feel bad for him but he's still the bad
guy
and i feel like the book makes that
pretty clear
but raul
i have a problem with like raul being
set up as like the hero because he's
also he also sucks
not as much but he still sucks
but
so i don't know to that degree it's
still kind of a romance but i don't know
it was it was a different time
they also did a 2004 film adaptation
and this had
gerard butler in it
i haven't seen it but i've seen like a
bunch of different uh commentaries on it
and uh
basically they kind of like really toned
down the
gruesomeness of the makeup in the gerard
butler run
so that it was just like oh he just has
like a couple scars on like one side of
his face
okay
and also there was a 1998
version with julian sands i love
julian's hand
uh where they didn't even bother with
the
malformations they just said well we'll
just make him a handsome [ __ ]
yeah
which kind of misses the point of it
it kind of misses the entire point of
the story it's supposed to be like a
beauty and the beast type story
well
not it's supposed to be like a dark side
of beauty and the beast i guess because
beauty and the beast is a story about
well don't judge people by what they
look like because the beast was like
a deep down was like an okay guy even
though he looked crazy
um phantom of the opera was not the dude
looked [ __ ] up he was and he was
[ __ ] up
so it's like yeah avoid that dude at all
cause yeah he looks bad yeah stay away
from him there's every reason for you to
stay away from that dude yeah so it was
almost kind of like
it was kind of like [ __ ] reinforcing
the stereotypes about terribly deformed
people yeah yes they're they're terrible
people please stay away from them people
are saying yeah 2004 phantom toned him
out and toned him down a lot yeah they
did yeah i've seen it yeah no
phantom wasn't a good guy even in the
original series absolutely not he was a
bad guy
and he was portrayed as a bad guy in the
novel
yeah in the novel he was a serial killer
he was out for your [ __ ] and if and he
if he had to kill your man to get to it
he would kill your man
and that then if you [ __ ] pissed him
off he'd kill you too
that's the way the phantom was yeah he's
a serial killer yeah he was like one of
those dudes yeah because i've been
watching
yeah i've been watching i've been
watching that show my crazy ex yeah he's
doing one of those i've been watching
that show and it's like some of those
dudes out there like look if i can't
have you know no one can have you all
right he's one of those kind of
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna watch
everything you do i'm gonna like say
because you belong to me right and
[ __ ] because
yeah and you're like oh then i have to
kill you he's one of those yeah yeah
not a good dude even
even in the original version
he's not he's portrayed
somewhat sympathetically like in the
fact that you know in this world he
he's portrayed as a pitiful but he yeah
he's portrayed as like pathetic yeah but
he's not portrayed as like a good guy
he's portrayed as like a villain no he's
a villain he couldn't help what happened
to him right but he was still a bad
person sure he couldn't help it though
and it's pretty clear in the book i
thought yeah that he's not supposed to
be no a romantic lead he's supposed to
be a bad guy yeah you can feel sorry for
him because he did have like a raw deal
yeah but
he's still
a bad guy and that was one of the things
that made me think that there might be
something to this story because the way
it was written
i thought it was out of character for
the 1800s jenny's saying no it's not out
of character they were way ahead of what
i was thinking yeah because they said
yeah he got a [ __ ] up deal he wasn't
it wasn't his fault that he ended up
like this
but he was [ __ ] crazy
that's what the [ __ ] yeah i mean it
didn't come right out and say that but
like i said from reading the novel
i was kind of like well
the way they're portraying eric in the
novel
it really does come acro at least to me
and this just might be my perception
at least to me it comes across it's like
well he's sympathetic in the sense that
you understand where he's coming from
yeah
but
he's still a bad guy whose actions are
not um
justifiable no what the story is saying
is that the story is saying
this could happen to anybody
that's what the [ __ ] story is
says that you could have been born like
this all right
and you would have been miserable and
done this [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] yeah
like maybe you would have done yeah if
you if you'd have the same upgrade
yeah that's what the story means
that's what it's saying
which i was just way ahead of what i
thought they were in the 1800s oh no way
you should read like some more
literature from back yeah i didn't i
wasn't aware yeah but i re like i said i
read a lot of [ __ ] from back then they
they were they weren't as uh behind as
you think they are based on what jenny's
telling me is that they fully grasp the
idea of
is that not everything is within your
hands sure and that
had the dice roll in a different way you
could have been this dude
they didn't always apply it in practice
right uh i will say that right but they
did seem to grasp it at least um
in in an intellectual sense yeah they
did seem to grasp that concept and
they're not saying he was a good dude
no
no
the the story does not paint him as a
hero no he's very much a bad guy they're
saying he's a [ __ ] tortured animal
who's [ __ ] turned to evil
sure in a certain way yeah
he's not a good guy no way and but that
could have been anybody based upon
what happened to him
and that
he came out this way because of the
[ __ ]
how he
was born
and uh that could be anybody but they're
also not saying he's innocent
there's just
they're just saying it is what it is
that's what they're saying yeah which i
kind of like that this is
the author is saying gaston is saying
this is [ __ ] tragic but it is what it
is
and this could have been still what
people say nowadays i mean when we talk
about serial killers like when we talk
about someone like aileen warno's
original
yeah it's like look they had horrible
childhoods right but it is what it is
but
that doesn't justify what they did later
right just put yourself in that position
what would happen
and i'm not saying that a lot of people
are put in the same position wouldn't
have turned out the same way i'm not i'm
just saying you have to give them a
little leeway because of that
but
to a point like you can't like justify
their actions later the horror in it is
the horror aspect of these stories is is
that it's not really in your hands
is that it could have been handed to you
and you wouldn't have been you wouldn't
had a choice and i kind of feel like
that's more horror that maybe is why
stories like this endure have endured
probably um and maybe
uh i i don't even know if people like
are
really all that cognizant of why
but i think that it's because
people are terrified whether they
realize it or not
of randomness yeah
um
we don't think of freedom of choice you
don't like the fact that like some bad
[ __ ] might happen to you and it has
nothing to do with anything you did
right it has nothing to do with how good
a person you are
um
[ __ ] just happens
because the universe is
indifferent indifferent to you because
we like to think of freedom of choice
sure
but to a large extent you do not have
yeah
the the freedom that is very frightening
isn't it as real as you think it is
is that random [ __ ] could have [ __ ]
forced stuff on you sure which just sent
you down a different path
and
and just trying to be a normal person
under those circumstances would have led
you into a situation where you're eric
from the phantom because imagine right
just imagine for a second that you were
born
looking like yeah all [ __ ] up and
you're intelligent which makes it worse
that's what i mean and like you were
fully self-aware like you weren't
you know mentally challenged in any way
right but you grew up
looking like
you know for the sake of argument
a living corpse a monster a monster
if you or or like the elephant man
because we talked about that when we
talked about david lynch if you ask me
the syphilitic people are worse than the
elephant man that's what i mean well if
you grew up you look like [ __ ]
looking like that iron maiden now think
of an entire lifetime of people reacting
to you yeah looking like that yeah what
would that do to you to your psyche yeah
especially if you were intelligent and
talented
and you knew because the book from what
i remember said talked about
the well he was intelligent and very
talented which made his suffering even
more
well yeah because he because he could
never well people that are
intelligent yeah and self-aware they're
always going to suffer more because
they're aware they're aware of what
they've been robbed of sure and it
twisted him even more
so i'm reading this and i'm going like
this had to have happened
but i'm underestimating gaston
gaston understood the human the human
[ __ ] condition
and the way people think
we always like to think that
we have [ __ ]
advanced like we're so much the time no
yeah no not really no they understood
they understood the human condition like
i said i read a lot of [ __ ] from back
then we're not really all that's boring
i thought it was something that happened
i understand a lot of stuff that was
like you know
there's like some stuff i read a lot of
stuff from back then
and there are a few things that i have
to look up because i'm like well wait
what does that mean because it's
referring to something that doesn't
exist anymore
but
most of the stuff is still pretty
relevant yeah we haven't changed that
much not really
no
not really
i thought that this might have been
based on something that actually
happened but i think jenny's convinced
me that it wasn't based on something
that happened well now i will say okay
he knew of other things like this
happened it's a compilation
it's like a compilation album
now let's say though like i said the
real the opera house is really there you
can go
there is a
quote like sort of a lake underneath not
really a lake but it's a cistern it's
kind of man-made so there's that that is
under there
um now
apparently i don't know
i kind of feel like maybe this happened
at the time but maybe this was later it
was kind of hard to
discern
whether
some of the rumors that existed about
this opera house
were contemporaneous to the time that
gaston rewrote this book or if they only
came into flower
after the book came out and became very
widespread so
just take everything with a grain of
salt
now it might have been
that there were rumors at the time i'm
not sure if this is true or not but
there might have been rumors at the time
that there was an architect named eric
uh with a c or eric with the k
uh whose backstory was kind of similar
to that of the phantom
um
now
it may be
that this rumor was circulating
in the early 20th century and gaston
larue may have heard it in 1908
so it's possible
that this was based on a real person who
was born with a disfigurement
like a tort in a circus
and
you know some other things that were
very similar to eric's story but like i
said i don't know if that's actually
true or not but there were some rumors
going around
now interestingly
uh there were rumors as i said that this
person
fell in love with a singer who did
perform at the palais garnier
um
but
he was rejected by the singer and then
kidnapped her
and then they found the singer three
weeks later she was still alive like he
didn't kill her or anything but he just
like let her really happen i don't know
i couldn't find any contemporary so
because you would think of like a singer
from like a high-profile opera house got
kidnapped
you would think that that was what but i
couldn't find any news sources that
would back that up but like i said this
was like a legend
now the legend goes
that this person
was so heartbroken after this happened
that he walled himself up
under the opera house and died of
starvation
now
uh again i think i mentioned this
earlier
that when the uh this opera house was
built they found the apartment
underneath and it's like they found the
skeleton with like the gold ring on it
which was kind of like one of the things
but i don't know as i said i couldn't
really find anything that corroborated
this
it could be that there was some vague
rumor going around at the time maybe and
then like but after
phantom of the opera came out it was
like a massive success
it might have like leached into the
cultural zeitgeist to a point where you
can't like tease apart now
because it could be that there was like
some vague [ __ ] that was going on before
that but once the story came out
everybody latched onto that
and what are you doing pookie stop
tearing [ __ ] up she's like we got a show
to do she's like [ __ ] you i'm going to
tear this [ __ ] up
she's just over there going
tearing my couch that's okay stop it
she just she's already done don't worry
about it but so i don't know if like
most of the details came into flower
like after
the story came out
and was kind of like there's it's very
unclear like how that happened
now there's also a rumor going around
that there was an uh okay so after an
1873
stage fire
a ballerina died
and her fiance who was a pianist and his
name was ernest
he got disfigured in the fire
and this pianist took up residence
underneath the building but then ended
up dying of his injuries
now this rumor though i don't know if
it's true or not
was originally attached
to a different
opera house
uh the sala pe paletiere
which was actually which actually
plta
whatever that is yeah okay
uh that actually did it was a real place
it did burn down in october of 1873 but
i don't i couldn't find i don't think
there were any fatalities though
in when it burned down a lot of [ __ ]
burned down back then because
of of the way that they constructed
things and the fact that they didn't
really have widespread electricity and
they were lighting everything with
questionable
lighting accessories let's say that
so this did actually burn down in 1873 i
don't know if anybody died in it
now the palais garnier
was built as a replacement
for that place
so the palais garnier where the phantom
of the opera was at was uh opened in
1875 or was inaugurated in 1875. so
allegedly there had been a legend about
this fire that happened the fire did
happen
but i don't know
if the thing about oh a ballerina died
and a dude was disfigured and there was
a whole thing about it you know what i
mean the fire happened
but i don't know if the other [ __ ]
happened i couldn't find any like
newspapers pookie looked at that plate
went [ __ ] this
that's just dried out well i gave it to
her this morning okay you'd give her
some treats if you where is it right
there there's streets right there okay
give her some
yeah she might be upset yeah i'm trying
not to give her like too much wet food
because
she only eats a little bit and then she
leaves it all
yeah so
it could be
that
gaston larue had heard about these
legends about this fire like i said the
fire is real it's documented i saw the
newspaper reports and everything
um but i don't think anybody died in it
as far as i can uh determine
but a legend did arise
about
a ballerina dying
in the fire
and her
fiance
being burned in the fire but surviving
and so there was a legend of that now
this place
was the place that burned down and then
later napoleon was like yeah we need to
build an opera house to like replace
that
so uh the the place where phantom of the
opera was set was like a replacement for
that place that had burned down so
there could be some like [ __ ] uh
thing there
so let's talk about like uh
i have some like really weird questions
in my google search
so hopefully if i ever murder anybody or
anything like that i'm gonna be in big
trouble because they look at my like
[ __ ] google search history yeah
hey i'm a horror writer and a true crime
writer i look up all kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] so
you know
i'm not going to kill anybody that i'm
planning on oh seth is in the in the
comp yeah
what's up says
she said she would definitely become a
bitter [ __ ]
yeah i can do that
and then hugo says i love the dark man
reviews by the way guys i checked my
dark mind back set dark man die dark man
die appears to be the third movie it is
but i think it's the second well from
what i heard yeah they shot it yeah
before they shot the second one i don't
know if that's true or not it feels like
it should be the second movie i mean it
feels like it should be watch him out of
order and i think it will make a lot
more sense
yeah maybe but they're good movies
i would love to have that i mean all of
them are good yeah i would love to see
three movie boxes i had only seen the
first one yeah
but they're all totally worth watching
yeah
all right so uh what genetic disorder
did eric either talking about the
character or the allegedly real person
we don't know if he's a real person or
not
what did he suffer from
uh so there are a lot of different
theories most of the theories kind of
concentrate on his psychological
[ __ ] which i'm not really interested in
i'm kind of interested in because
there's a lot of stuff that would make
him act all crazy like that
what made him look like
a [ __ ] skull that's what i wanted to
know
so uh to that end
i found a delightful
blog post
by a
by a paleo anthropologist
paleo a paleo pathologist rather
named uh arianny schultz
and she had the same question as me
she's like what [ __ ] disease did this
[ __ ]
suffer from
syphilis
and she kind of okay she's like this was
her quote either
acquired or congenital syphilis yeah
but
we could also be looking at hansen's
disease leprosy leprosy yeah also uh
paget's disease which is
the same disease that allegedly um
afflicted the woman that if you guys
know the very famous portrait by quentin
masseys
that was like uh i can't remember what
it's called but like a a weird old woman
i don't know i've seen it it was in the
met and the woman looks like all
deformed and [ __ ] up it's a great
painting though i love it
um and some people think that she might
suffer from that because she had like
some
issues
with their fingernails
uh no i don't know her her hands weren't
in it was just her face
but that was that so it could be pagie
syndrome
uh pages disease rather uh could be
osteomyelitis could be
proteus syndrome which is the same thing
that elephant man had yeah uh or uh
plagiocephaly but she
came down on the side of she's like i
think this is probably
uh congenital
syphilis yeah i would think so too that
would explain the most common the facial
deformities because that usually causes
uh facial lesions yeah the uh kind of
lack of a nose or like the appearance of
lashes all the photographs yeah there's
that
um and also like the emotional
volatility like all kind of the like
psychological stuff that was displayed
she's like that seems like the most
likely candidate yeah
but go read that post because it's like
super funny
now before we did this movie as you did
this show i went to
i mentioned to jenny
i said i was reading that book
back in 2000
four maybe
two running that time
and i remembered it describing what was
wrong with him as something kind of like
a kid that i went to [ __ ] middle
school with him in in
in dominguez elementary school had
he had something wrong with him and his
fingernails were thick they were a
quarter of an inch thick
it was like it was yellow foam
it was the weirdest thing his head was
shaped like a [ __ ] peanut
and he had a corpse like [ __ ]
appearance
and his hair was falling out and he was
third grade
which like i said that's kind of sounds
like the [ __ ] phantom
his [ __ ] lips
looked like open [ __ ] scabs and his
[ __ ] gums had pulled up over his
teeth
and uh and you didn't know like what did
you
he had friends though it was weird we
were like friends with him but he and he
was falling apart he was
he was not happy with what was happening
to him he's becoming well i can imagine
he's becoming more and more violent i
don't know if he lived or not
but
that might have been that his mother or
father might have had syphilis maybe
because it is
heritable you can pass it on yeah maybe
i don't know what happened to him but
that that's but i remember his
fingernails
i mean we have fingernails that are
[ __ ] as thin as a [ __ ] couple
sheets of paper maybe
his were a quarter of an inch thick
and they were [ __ ] yellow and they
were like foam dried foam
and he would do that and he would just
[ __ ] crumble out i remember that
that's crazy yeah
i couldn't find much about that but like
i said
um everything i looked up like for
making your face look like a skull yeah
syphilis was the most likely candidate
and honestly that was like pretty common
back in those days yeah and if you had
congenital syphilis in the sense that
like your mom had it or your dad had it
and passed it on to you
i tried to find the photograph of a
person who had a congenital syphilis
from the 1800s that was [ __ ] black
and white photograph and i don't know if
it was male or female look just like
eddie off the [ __ ] iron maiden album
yeah it was
i mean there's a lot of different things
it could be but
i mean according to this one blog post
she's like well i've looked into it
she's like there's a lot of diseases it
could be yeah but she's like the most
likely thing depending on you know the
the description
was probably congenital syphilis
probably
and that might have explained like why
his mom was just kind of like yep out of
here yeah maybe she was sick too
you know what i mean so it could have
been that
because i kind of feel like there was
some
there was a kind of whole tale about a
real person existing that
was maybe the uh
inspiration
for eric but nobody knows if that's true
or not though nobody knows that person
really existed
but if he did exist it's possible that
he could have had
uh syphilis congenital syphilis because
that would explain like your face
looking like that
you know yeah that would do it
now i will say
that terry says sorry jenny but you're
guilty of what i'm not i don't know who
knows entirely sure
i'm sure i'm guilty of a lot of things i
don't really remember what it was that i
was talking about
now whether eric was based on a real
person or not
the character of christine
is absolutely based on a real person
uh
now when he was dying
uh gaston larue said the person the
character was based on a real opera
singer quote whose real name i hid
under that of christine daye
yeah
now didn't take too much sleuthing to
discover that the real person he was
probably talking about
was a swedish
opera singer named christina or
christine nilsson
who lived from 1843 to 1921.
her real life was very very close to the
fictional life
written about in the novel
uh so nelson the real person just like
the fictional person was born in rural
sweden
both were discovered by rich patrons
while they were performing in a swedish
marketplace
the real person
uh was singing alongside her brother's
violin playing
in the book she's discovered singing
alongside her fathers violin playing so
similar there
and the cities were
similar um although
gaston larue fictionalized the name of
the town
to liamby
instead of
liangby which it really was in sweden
i'm not sure i'm not saying that right
uh both the fictional character and the
real person
were uh taken under taken uh into
custody by a fictional by a family
called the valerius family in gothenburg
sweden
both of them were brought to paris by
their patrons for
training and opera singing
um
even the whole thing in the novel about
christine daye being like a rival with
carlotta the spanish
diva
is
partially based on real [ __ ]
because there was a thing where
there was this whole competition in real
life going on with uh christina nelson
the real person
and uh another diva named caroline
miolan caro carvalho
cavallo carvalho carvalho who
yeah who uh they were going after the
same role in faust which is the same
thing that happened in the book
um during 1868 1869
and in the book he even used quotes and
uh same kind of stuff from like reviews
that were really published at that time
in the papers one drink uh yeah sure why
not all right
so like i said he did use a lot of real
[ __ ] i mean there was
christine was based on a real person he
used like the real biography he used
real her real
quote-unquote rivalry with this other
singer he used um quotes from actual
reviews actual uh you know uh
articles that came out at the time about
their rivalry so he did use that
there was a lot of real [ __ ] going on in
the [ __ ]
now let's talk about i tried to find
this was like really difficult
i was trying to figure out
because in the novel
it does seem to imply
i don't know if it implies this but it
does kind of like
lean hard into the fact that
the opera house is
haunted
and like i said you find out later that
obviously the opera ghost is a person
but
i was trying to figure out thank you i
was trying to figure out if there were
actually rumors that this opera house
which exists in real life
was haunted
at the time that this book came out like
i was trying to figure out were there
rumors that this place was haunted when
he wrote the [ __ ] and like he was
influenced by that
and that is no that's like really
difficult to like figure out i couldn't
really find a lot of [ __ ] about it there
was a lot of stuff that was like from a
modern point of view like there were a
lot of paranormal websites that said oh
yeah there's like this that and the
other ghost in there
but
i couldn't really find any sources from
that time
that said that there were
stories about a ghost
from then that he would have taken
inspiration from you know what i'm
saying so
i don't know i was like it was really
frustrating because i was like trying to
find
evidence of it and i couldn't really
find it
now according to some people and i don't
know if this is like modern or from the
time or whatever
but
even if the [ __ ] was haunted like the
opera house
the ghost
doesn't have anything to do with like a
genius musician or anything like that
like the ghost that's been seen
reportedly
is like some older woman
who
was like scorned in love or whatever and
she just kind of like hangs around the
streets outside the opera house like
looking for the dude that [ __ ] her
over
um that's kind of like the main ghost
that i could so i don't
know
if there were ghost stories about it at
the time i kind of feel like when he
wrote it
he was drawing from
actual [ __ ] that happened like i said
the death that absolutely did happen
there like when the counterweight from
the chandelier fell down and killed a
person um that did happen
uh you know the [ __ ] about the
water underneath the opera house which
like i said that is it's not a lake
really but
you know there's a lot of caverns and
like secret passages down there that did
happen uh the whole thing about the dead
bodies that they found from like the
paris commune
um you know from when they stored [ __ ]
ammunition and stuff down there that
happened the whole stuff about the
records being stored down there that
happened so i kind of feel like maybe
he took all those real elements
and maybe the legend about
uh the guy that burned to death with the
ballerina which
was from the old opera house
which was before this one was
built
um and maybe he like fashioned that into
a story
i kind of feel that's where i'm at with
it
so
did he base this on a real thing
yeah in a lot of ways he did
um
but
he took a lot of real things that
happened and wove them into a fictional
story and like i said in a way that
even nowadays people are still like
questioning whether
it's real or not which is pretty
admirable you gotta say like i said
you probably like you should read more
fiction from that era
because you would uh
you would realize pretty quickly that
they were like pretty savvy about
okay back up again i was gone during
part of that so you're saying that
he wrote this it was based on certain
things
yeah he based a lot of things on the leg
cr the character christine based on a
real person okay very obviously all
right uh
he didn't make much of a secret of that
and honestly if you just look into it
for a second you will know that who who
he's talking about okay it's a real
person
um
the opera house is obviously real
um it's still there the night of the
fire the uh the fire yeah
well okay
the fire
that
supposedly killed a person and
disfigured another person that didn't
happen at that opera house that happened
at the prior one which burned down
in 1873 she inflated
he conflated this one they had a okay
the thing that happened with this one
was like the the chandelier falling
which is like a big thing yeah it wasn't
exactly like that it did happen
but it happened uh it was a
counterweight from the chandelier like i
said
it was
kind of a fire that caused it
electric light caused a spark it melted
the wire
the wire
melted through and the counterweight
fell and killed a person in the audience
yeah the counterweight when it was
coming down hit
a uh like a fuse box type situation and
started a fire
it didn't like tear it didn't burn the
[ __ ] down or anything they put it out so
it only kill it killed one person and
injured some other people but everything
was okay after that but it was like a
big deal
so he used that
in the story
and he
made it into oh the chandelier fell and
it killed this one particular person but
that's not exactly what happened you
know what i'm saying it did kill a
person
but
it wasn't even the chandelier it was
like the counterweight from the
chandelier
so [ __ ] did happen but he's taking a lot
of real elements
and
putting them all together in like a soup
okay if you will let me ask you this is
this a real
deception that he's trying to do or is
he conflating things that he found
i think well okay you have to like gas
on larue
was really into
like i said he started out his career as
a reporter yeah but
he wrote a bunch of mystery novels he
was really into like arthur conan doyle
he was really into edgar allan poe so he
was really into like
mystery crime thrillers that kind of
stuff so he was in the scene so he had
written a couple of those before this
even came out okay
um like i said i mentioned this earlier
in 1908 yeah before this came out yeah
he wrote a novel called the perfume of
the lady in black which was made
yeah it was made into a giallo film in
1974. it was made again in 2005 but it
was actually made into like there were
film adaptations going to 1914 i think
there were like two or three of them so
it was like he was really into like
mystery stories
so he was trying to get into like
writing fiction crime fiction and
because he was into sherlock holmes and
edgar allan poe and all that kind of
stuff he wanted her like horror mystery
um so i think what he did
was he conflated he decided that he's
like i'm gonna take my experience in
you know newspaper like reporting yeah
and i'm gonna like conflate it with
fiction
okay and make it seem like
a real thing
honestly so you're saying this is this
is an intentional deception
i don't know if it was deception i just
think that he said i'm going to take all
these elements that happened in real
life
and i'm going to like weave them into a
fictional story i don't think he was
trying to like deceive anybody
well because they said because he did
say that he was yeah that he really did
invest but the thing about it here's the
thing all right
um
i was talking about earlier how hard it
was because i was trying to figure out
um
i was curious as to whether
this opera house was rumored to be
haunted
at the time that he wrote the story i'm
not talking about nowadays right because
you can say anything else always ghosts
and blah blah i said i wanted to know
were people talking about the ship being
haunted back then
when he wrote it
and i kind of couldn't find anything
that said that
there were rumors about other things
or
not necessarily rumors but like stuff
that was like kind of
you know weird versions of the truth
like [ __ ] that really happened but it
was like exaggerated i couldn't find any
ghost stories though
so i kind of feel like baby the ghost
[ __ ] happened afterward after his story
came out
that's the kind of the hard thing
because his story is so
became so ubiquitous
that anything you read nowadays is going
to be colored by that
so it's like now people like oh yeah a
ghost and blah blah but it's just kind
of like yeah but were people talking
about ghosts
back then
or what or did that just happen later
because this place is so famous because
of that you know what i'm saying yeah
and it was like notoriously like it was
very hard to like figure out i couldn't
find anything that said that there were
ghost stories contemporaneous
with his
writing of this story
i feel like that was probably happened
after the story came out
and people
went back and said oh yeah the [ __ ] was
[ __ ] haunted opera ghost but that's
like from the novel though
i don't know i kind of feel like that's
probably what happened
now i will say though that i did find
this one thing
that um
this one guy who was a curator of the
museum at the palais garnier
uh uh and library
he said that he still gets calls every
day
and he gets asked
is this story of the fan of the upper
true
and he says what we like to say
and this is a quote from him
we don't like to break the illusion
but nobody has seen a ghost in the opera
house
although we do blame the phantom as a
joke if something inexplicable happens
so
apparently like no one in the modern era
thinks that [ __ ] is on it
but they like to like maintain that it's
still kind of haunted now i will say too
let let me finish this i only got like a
paragraph left
i found this woman named uh
maria ribier
and she translated the phantom of the
opera she's like big into like gaston
larue she's big and a fan of albert she
translated
uh the version that was published uh by
penguin in 2009 she translated it from
the
french and she says
um i'm pretty sure the whole phantom
story was made up
she says
gaston larue was a flamboyant
larger-than-life character
and he reacted as anyone would
with all of hollywood
for example
asking if the phantom was real
if your make-believe has been so
successful
this is a quote that people ask the
question you are not going to destroy
the illusion right if people wanted to
believe that he had existed he was not
going to disappoint them that's how i
see it but having said that perhaps he
really did believe it
so basically
for her and many other scholars that
have looked into the [ __ ]
um
gaston was a very groundbreaking
groundbreaking reported journalist
and he was uh really good at writing
detect novels
and he was able to weave fact and
fiction together
so skillfully that people are still
asking questions about it to this day
and he may have believed it
he might have you may have believed it i
mean and that might have made it better
like right
but let's talk about reality
i would like to think that maybe there's
something to this story
but there might be there might be but
the story hinges on something
it says that the phantom lived
underneath the [ __ ]
theater
in a house on an island
on a underground lake
and that part doesn't pan out
it also says that he had secret passages
all throughout there were a couple of
secret passages in the thing but not
as i said they're not as romantic as
portrayed there are still two they're
still there you can still see them
because the phantom would go from his
house
on that island underneath the lake
up to
a special
box where well his box five where he
would watch there was just like a like a
pipe
and like he could go up there because
yeah he would go up there and sit but
like he couldn't like if somebody else
was in there you're right he would go in
there loud he could get out his own he
could like talk to you and like you
couldn't see him that was like his whole
thing and another thing too was that he
could get into christine's
dressing room right he had that mirror
forgot about that went like two ways
right so he could just like talk to you
from that other side of the starlet's
dressing room the main number one stars
dress in the room
and that there was a
secret passage to that
did that pan out
was there a secret passage
to the starlet strat uh [ __ ] dressing
room
well not nowadays like i said there are
two secret passages yeah in the opera
house
but
i don't as far as i know they don't go
to like anyone's dressing room okay
there's just one that goes from the
basement up to the fourth floor
and there's one that
is just kind of like they it's not even
like they just use it with like a water
[ __ ] yeah
so
the story could be plausible
but not as [ __ ] high speed as you're
given in the
story well like i said i kind of feel
like he did what some people do now
embellished you take
a real story yeah i'm gonna okay this is
a weird example
but this is just something i thought i
was just in the bathroom i thought of
this
um if you guys have read and i've
reviewed it jack kesham's book the girl
next door
the girl next door is a fictional novel
but it is based on a real
uh true crime case a
horrible case that really really did
happen
he fictionalized it he changed all the
names
um
but it's based on a real murder the
murder of sylvia likens
now he changed the names he changed some
of the details
but and the locations and stuff like
that but it's still essentially the same
story so i kind of feel like that's
probably
what gaston larue did he probably took a
bunch of
real things the fact that there's a
water sister and underneath the thing
the fact that the there were rumors
about
you know the skeletons that they found
like when they were digging for the
you know to bury the records so he adds
that to his and then he just decided
well i'm gonna do this but i'm gonna
embellish it
and then
as i said he adds the prologue to give
it some like very similitude because
like i said
i kind of feel like you're not
if you read a lot of victorian fiction
they were absolutely all about
making the stuff seem as real as
possible
a lot of stories from back then
are framed as though they are real
stories
there's some of what jenny's saying
literature of the time was kind of like
writing code
in the internet of the of our time
writing a story was considered to be
very high tech only and only very
educated people did it
and intelligent people wrote these
stories
so yeah they could have twisted things
around
kind of make a vr
virtual reality
second i can understand that
as i said i kind of feel like people
nowadays are maybe kind of smug in the
fact that they think that oh
found footage or like you know air g
type situation oh that's new it's not
if you go back and read
late 19th century early 20th century
horror fiction in particular which is my
interest
if you read a lot of stuff from back
then even from like weird tales and
stuff like that
a lot of them are framed
as though they
really happened yeah um they will have
like a frame story
uh it's very common to have a frame
story to of somebody that i've i'm an
adventurer and i've just come back from
some exotic location
um i was a skeptic i don't believe in
anything but listen to this weird [ __ ]
that happened to me when i was on this
latest adventure and then he tells it to
the people
you know what i mean so they're trying
to frame it as though it really happened
um it's very common in literature of
that era so i don't think that like the
phantom of the opera story was
all that different in that regard
um in the fact that he was coming
forward as the author and saying because
i've seen similar things like in short
stories
uh from the time period where the author
would come forward and say
i don't know i don't believe this but
somebody i really somebody i really like
trust like told me this [ __ ] and i'm
just like telling it to you guys so make
your own decision so i kind of feel like
there's a lot of that going on so it
wasn't unheard of is what i'm saying
well all i have to say about it is that
around 2002 2003 or in that time when i
was reading this
old gaston back in [ __ ]
1906 or 1907 had me going 1909 1909. he
said it was okay he had me going
it is plausible it sounds very plausible
sure it could have happened but he wrote
that [ __ ] to be in a gray space where
maybe it could happen
and i can see how that old [ __ ]
fooled me
but that's
they're not
you're not as smart as you think you are
those dudes are pretty [ __ ] good they
were good
well like i said i'm a writer and i'm
really into like writers from that era
yeah they understood the deal they were
absolutely not they knew the human mind
they were absolutely not stupid
yeah and they used a lot of the same
tricks that people use nowadays yeah
okay
so you know any sound footage kind of
stuff yeah right and then they give
themselves plausible deniability
yep because they don't give you enough
detail to disprove them
and like i said he did base some of the
character like christine is absolutely
based on a real person that's based on a
real person so it could have happened
but probably not
and he's kind of like leaving it open
like well
i wrote this it's like fictionalized but
it could have really happened because he
did base a lot of [ __ ] like i said the
palette that's the opera house that's
real
the christine is based on a real person
right so he did base a lot of stuff on
real [ __ ] that happened
but
you know
my advice is
this on you on youtube there are many um
audio books there's one on this nine
hours long it's got some british girl
right now it is verbatim from this
from the book that i read
uh it's got the [ __ ] prologue and
everything it's pretty good
uh i i [ __ ] listened to that prologue
and a little bit of little little bit of
that one and then i went over into um
the uh christopher lee christopher lee
which is abridged but it's only three
hours that one is actually a little bit
better in terms of well the well it's a
little more entertaining nine and
something hour one i listened to that
one yeah and that's librivox which
librivox if you don't know
is
that's like a public domain that's like
volunteers just
right read
um you know literature for people to
listen to
so what they did with the
phantom of the opera was that they had
like different narrators reading
a few chapters
now i'm not okay
i'm not [ __ ] on anybody in the
country particularly but
a lot of the
narrators that they got
were
midwestern
and the midwestern voices
uh pronouncing the french stuff
was kind of like
making me cringe a little bit right some
of the like some of the voices were kind
of like
and it was like but
they were only reading like a chapter or
two
and then it would like go to another one
uh the prologue was read by a british
woman
which she was good
but then the first couple chapters were
like a woman from like
cancer missouri or somewhere like that
and she had like a really weird
uh inflection
and her french pronunciation was
uh questionable like even worse than
mine
and so it was distracting but i still
like listen to it and then there was a
guy so there was like a bunch of
different readers the christopher lee
was the [ __ ] slickest i mean yeah
christopher lee
but that one was like highly abrasive
highly abridged i mean that was only
like what like three and a half hours or
yeah or something like that and like
the real book is like nine and a half
ten hours long
and i will admit that there is a lot of
that book that could be
cut out probably
yeah but
i don't know i enjoyed the entire book
even though it goes back and forth in
time a lot
like i said it goes back
to
the new managers
yeah
and like that's almost kind of like
comic relief yeah like because they
don't believe the ghost exists
so it's kind of like their their mission
to like is to tell you this [ __ ] didn't
happen
we're gonna find the person that's
behind this god damn it and it's like
it's just so it keeps going back what's
funny is that that kind of adds on to
this it does i like that
this may have happened i like it it
makes you start to fight for the story
going like now this may have happened
um
but no gaston knew exactly what he was
doing that french [ __ ]
he knew exactly what he was doing he
knew how to [ __ ] see people hundreds
of years ago still fool you he knew how
to how to play with you they weren't
there
yeah
it may have happened but it probably
didn't
well like i said he he didn't pull it
out of his ass
he based it on
real [ __ ]
and he based it on
yeah legends
that were going around at the time he
didn't know if they were real or not but
he didn't give a [ __ ] he's just kind of
like well my advice is to listen to the
[ __ ] gaston gaston [ __ ] story i
actually kind of enjoyed it because it
is legend it may have happened it
probably didn't but it [ __ ] if it did
happen
it's not that big of a deal you're
talking about a serial killer that
probably had syphilis
i mean he did kill a lot of people and
and so it's not like the claims
by today's standards are super [ __ ]
uh out of the ordinary they're not
claiming anything supernatural they're
just claiming about yeah they had this
dude and he was stuck in this serial
killer he was [ __ ] super smart
[ __ ] was ugly he didn't have a
nose something was wrong with him it
might have been syphilis but [ __ ]
this dude was a genius he had torture
castles kind of like h.h holmes [ __ ] was
underground he was [ __ ] grabbing
women taking him underground trying to
marry him they wouldn't do it he'd kill
him
he killed the [ __ ] boyfriends and
it's just like and they're like and you
know what that he was [ __ ] up
but it wasn't his fault he was born that
way and yeah his his life [ __ ] sucked
it could have happened to you and all
this [ __ ] is kind of like hitting you in
this [ __ ] story where you're like
going this may have happened
this may have happened
but jenny's right but some aspects of it
probably but yeah but jenny's right
an expert author can really mind [ __ ]
you
into thinking that's kind of our whole
job that's the that's the job because
he's trying to write vr he's trying to
write virtual reality
i mean that's what right i mean i'm a
horror writer too yeah and i read a lot
of horror authors
what i want from my horror stories i
want you to immerse me right immerse me
in that [ __ ]
and
to do that sometimes you have to
stretch the truth a little bit you have
to kind of like and i'm i'm down with
that we're all like just buying into the
illusion we're buying into the illusion
because
we want to be
scared we want to feel a particular
thing
yeah so
they understood that back then uh they
had horror fiction back then
and they understood what scared people
um so
they knew
how to approach that
to make it seem as realistic as possible
and so i think that's probably what he
did he used as many real aspects as he
could muster
because as i said
the setting was a was real a lot of the
characters were based on real people
there are other dudes that are like this
yeah yeah i mean that's what you do
you're right that's what you do
my
i'm gonna tell you now
my verdict on it is probably not but
[ __ ] baby
maybe
maybe he did stumble on something
you know
it's not that far
from the other cases that we covered
the main difference was is that he had a
lot of money
and that he had syphilis
but it explains how he got all that
money because he was a [ __ ] genius he
was working for
a sultan that had him in the
intelligence agent his intelligence
agencies as a torturer
and a at a [ __ ]
architect
which that's well within
the boundaries of plausibility
uh from what i remember in the book
he kept himself covered when he was in
the middle east
kind of like wearing a
fedor or a shadow or whatever it is
[ __ ] keeping himself covered up kind
of like a middle eastern woman
but he didn't have any kind of
relationships over there because of
[ __ ] how he looked and his smell and
his just
but his employer [ __ ] liked him
because he was a results-based dude yeah
and no that is plausible that's very
plausible
jenny's gonna come in and say well
gaston was [ __ ] an intelligent guy he
knew how to [ __ ] fool you
to write a story that would be plausible
and and i'm going to say yeah
yeah that could be but life is also
plausible [ __ ] that happens in life is
plausible
so uh
you just don't know you don't know
i mean i had a gut feeling when i was
[ __ ] reading it is that there was
truth in it
at least
well there is there is truth in it right
it was a good it's a good story it's a
very good story i encourage you to
[ __ ] listen to it it is a very good
story
i actually had a good is it true i'm
gonna say probably not
at least not a hundred percent of
interest i think aspects aspects are
very true right it's a [ __ ]
i don't think anyone would argue with
that that's a good good story
it's based on a real place yeah uh it's
based on some real people yeah it's
based on some
[Music]
legends that may or may not have
happened there are offenders that fit
this profile hh home fits this profile
and as i said i've never seen any direct
evidence of it but it's very possible
that uh gaston larry might have read
about hh holmes and incorporated that
into his
lore
because
yeah that happened
ended 19th century 1896 he was
executed
late 1800s early 1900s serial killers
were a [ __ ] trip so i mean that and
jack the ripper was 1888 so that was
like so that was like living memory yeah
for people that were writing back then
so uh very possibly he could have taken
inspiration from that it is a spooky
story classy
very classy it's written
and um
either story if you want to listen to
the nine hour
audio book that's on youtube where the
christopher lee three and something a
half hour they were both good uh
christopher lee's performance is good
um the nine and a half hour version is a
lot more complete because it has that's
three things
it has it has the prologue it has every
[ __ ] bit in it
and that
that's more kind of like
a crime case
the way it reads i mean the thing about
like you can read it i mean obviously
it's in the public domain so you can
read it on gutenberg.org
um
i found
that because
the
uh
you know plot of phantom of the opera is
so ubiquitous nowadays because everybody
knows that [ __ ] even if they've never
seen any iteration of it
they know pretty much like the outline
of what happens in the story so it's
like if you read the novel
the first
third or half of it
is a little bit tiresome because you're
just kind of like a lot of the first
part of it is like this whole build up
of it's like oh my god is this opera
ghost is this real like what's going on
it's like everybody knows look it's this
weird deformed dude that lives like in
the basement figure it out but they
didn't know that at the time yeah you
know what i mean now greenspark says it
would suck to have an std eating your
brain and your face off and still be a
virginal incel no wonder he was pissed
off yeah that's the [ __ ] that's what
i'm saying that's the story you read the
story and you'll understand and then
pile on that you're a genius
and you know what's happening you could
have had a [ __ ] awesome life you made
a bunch of money
nothing
no women would not not anything i mean
well he was like composing musical
beautiful buildings and architecture
but there's just no way his life is
[ __ ] [ __ ] no women want anything to
do with him
and and well even if even like barring
that you couldn't even like walk around
like back then you couldn't even like
walk around in public
like people back then would like [ __ ]
throw rocks at you like i said
even now it wouldn't be fun right but
probably
better than back then but so he goes
back to his home in france with all this
money after these contract jobs in the
middle east and buys this [ __ ]
theater and has these lawyers build it
up for him and he shows up with all
these secret passages so he can watch
the theater which is really the
television of the uh of his era so he
could see all this [ __ ] and he becomes
entranced
by these starlets
and um
can't do anything with them
you know and he owns a theater and
everything
and that's the story
and it's not this romantic [ __ ]
that the phantom of the opera became
[ __ ] was a serial killer he was
crazy pretty much yeah yeah
yeah he was crazy and like i said he was
portrayed right
slightly sympathetically in the book but
he's he was [ __ ] up i mean he's the
bad guy yeah he's back there wasn't he
couldn't grow into anything outside of
what he was yeah you know
not in that society
so um
yeah yeah i felt and gaston was telling
you look you need to feel for this guy
he didn't choose this
but he's [ __ ] up
well like i said we've talked about a
lot of serial killers on the show it's
like you're kind of like that
yeah like you do feel like as children
right obviously because they didn't
choose that and it's like nobody wants
to grow up like that and it's like you
can understand
where their pathology came from
but when they get older
and they start
uh killing people right then
it's harder to excuse it
because honestly a lot of people have
[ __ ] up childhood yeah and they don't
do that in the phantom book
he's a sadist
he had killed a bunch of people before
the story story even started he was
killing him for his boss
yeah if you angered him if you angered
him he tortured you to death
okay you're not talking about a good
dude
yeah he was not a good guy no not at all
honestly like even before like i said he
had been
you know he grew up in the circus and
all this stuff but then he went to work
for
uh the sultan yeah
and one of the things in the story
that he would do was that the sultan
would be like hey um i'm gonna i'm gonna
need you to like fight and kill this
person like it for my amusement
so he would do that like he would kill
people yeah like he would they would do
like gladiator yeah like he would do
like gladiator combat yeah and he's like
oh we're gonna like bring a criminal in
here and you fight kill you fight and
kill them yeah
for the amusement of like the ruling
class so he would do that as well
and he um would also was also an
assassin
so they're kind of like hey go kill that
person he would do that too
so he had killed like a lot of people
even before the story started and he had
a lot of money
yeah because of that assault liked him
although the persian yeah was initially
supposed to
assassinate him
oh really yeah i didn't remember that
because he knew too much okay so after
he was released from service the persian
was supposed to kill him to erase his
ass yes but the persian actually like
had a soft spot for him it was like nah
i'm not gonna do it so they both took
off okay so that's why they were friends
that's why they were friends okay the
persian was actually supposed to be his
assassin that was like kind of the whole
thing but he was just yeah he was just
kind of like uh no i'm not gonna do it
because i like him too much so i'm not
gonna kill him so that yeah yeah so
there was that aspect also right
so
so the move so the book has a lot of
elements that
you probably that you don't get out of
these [ __ ] musicals that they made
based on this
it was a plausible story for the 18
early 1900s it's the way it's the way
the world was
you know
so i was [ __ ] reading it going there
might be something to this
but gaston mia got me he probably got me
well like i said if you don't know a lot
about the time period or you don't know
i mean whether the real time period or
the literary time period yeah um the
more you know about the context of the
time
the more you will feel like
this is just a fictional story that is
made to look like
he was good a real story he was good he
did use a lot of real elements i'm not
saying that
like i said christine is absolutely a
real that's a real person
um
he based her on a real absolutely real
person
um
and the paris opera house that's a real
place
the [ __ ] underneath that's a real thing
um
you know the chandelier falling that
really did happen mostly
but
he just took all this real elements and
fashioned
a story about it tammy says it was a
great show
was it that's what she said wow
i had fun with this yeah yeah i think
yeah i think it was a good show thank
you very much tammy we want to go ahead
and want to go ahead and end the show
we'll wrap it up wait how about how long
oh man i think i got four hours yeah
it's time to go
yeah
i did have a good time with this this is
a good idea for a topic right this is a
good idea i got super into this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i went to so many private holes you
guys don't know right
like learn about the stuff but
i mean if you guys have other ideas let
me know but yeah everybody saying they
love the show sabrina says she loves it
never heard much of this book before now
i
now that i have i'm going to read it and
give it a read you should i mean the
audiobook like i said i listened to
audiobook on youtube
and it's a bunch of different
narrators which i don't love
because some of the narrators were
better than others i like the british
narrators and they had like a bunch of
like weird midwestern ones that were
pronouncing the friendship all wrong and
it was like i don't know it was like
annoying me
but
it's pretty good overall there is an
abridged version which christopher lee
read but it's only what is it three
three and a half hours three and a half
hours it's more like a movie yeah the
actual book is like nine and a half
hours yeah if you have all the details
that i read now if you want to get
[ __ ] set up like a [ __ ] virtual
reality book i'm telling you i thought
it was real reading it i was going like
this must have happened
and i didn't know that he had
on his deathbed
told his his relatives like no that did
happen
he said that it happened on his deathbed
was he
keeping his legend alive i can't tell
you i wasn't there
victorians did that kind of [ __ ] but
i mean something may have happened it's
plausible it's all branding [ __ ] it's
brandy yeah they understood that [ __ ]
yeah they didn't call it that right but
they understood what that was they have
that terminology they understood what
that was yeah so i kind of feel like
it's really plausible that he was just
kind of like dude
i'm dying but it's like people are
asking me is this real he's like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah well he said he invested
he said that he investigated
whoever you've uh you know
made to like have your money after you
die yeah um
you don't want them like to be stuck out
to be stuck out with no money right so
you got to like keep the [ __ ] going
maybe the [ __ ] go maybe they understood
that
it's everything is plausible just listen
to the story it's free it's in the
public domain and you you tell us what
you think
i think there might be something to it
um it's a good book i i actually like i
enjoyed like revisiting it it's actually
pretty entertaining i thought it was if
that didn't happen other [ __ ] just like
it did happen so
that'll give you an idea go ahead and
shut it down jenny it's [ __ ] almost
four four or something hours all right
yeah tammy said this has been a great
show very interesting thank you very
much thanks jenny tom agree they're just
the best says greensbark and uh james
now says yeah it's very interesting love
this episode never heard much of the
book before now i have to i'm gonna go
give it a read yeah it's actually like a
really i mean it's very of the time yeah
uh so it's very like you know gothic and
stuff and yeah if you i mean everybody
knows the story of the phantom of the
opera now
so
one of the issues that you might uh come
into is that
there's a big build up it's like oh my
god is this like is it real is it like
who is this person it's like now
everybody knows
the phantom of that he's a real dude and
is like deformed and stuff so it might
be like
a little tedious
like
how long it takes for them to like
figure that out because they didn't know
that at the time but you could always go
to the [ __ ] christopher lee reading
yeah which is only three i mean i listen
to the whole yeah nine and a half hour
thing yeah but
you you could lift this to the prologue
of the nine and a half hour one and then
go to the christopher lee one that'll
save you time too
but he's just
it's just telling you a story about
a serial killer it's plausible
maybe it happened maybe it didn't that
that's all it is
there's no way of knowing it was a long
time ago probably didn't happen
because that is not exactly the way
right yeah i just think that he took a
lot of real aspects and moved them into
as described in the book it probably
didn't happen because that island isn't
there
underneath that
well like i said you can see it there's
pictures right there's no island
underneath you might even be able to
tour it right i've heard some like
recent accounts of people that actually
like toured it there's an underground
lake
but it's not a natural lake and there
isn't a island on it and there isn't a
mansion on the damn island
and thinking about it in the victorian
age had this happened
and there was a match in there and a
phantom have been killing people they'd
have been putting people through tours
of that damn mansion yeah you'd think
that for months and months and months
to show that damn mansion
so i'm gonna take that away from guston
he he made at least that part up
yeah
but he kind of says that in a way he
gives himself a bunch of plausible
deniability yeah
uh that's all i'm gonna say about
because i think he kind of
hints that he's telling you a story
based upon what his research says
well [ __ ]
you do some research and you base the
story upon your research that means you
kind of have literary license to say
things sure
you could say hey it wasn't me it was my
summer yeah
right
so there's no way we all know that trick
right
yeah we all know that yeah
all right
uh says i'm gonna go read the phantom of
the opera now you should it's actually
like
i i found the book like pretty
entertaining yeah like i said the first
part of it might be tedious for
audiences now because everybody knows
what the phantom of the opera is
um because the first half of the book is
basically everybody being like we saw
this ghost and they're like you didn't
see nothing you didn't see a ghost what
are you talking about so like the first
half of that is like kind of like that
but
i don't know i i find it really
entertaining nonetheless
but uh yeah so yeah seth says you
wouldn't kill the legend yeah i kind of
feel like maybe he was just kind of like
yeah i'm dying but yeah i'm not going to
tell a legend yeah
true or not
says marley mars uh very clever on
gaston's part because the book is still
fairly well known yeah yeah i mean still
making movies based on got to say
yeah they made one in 2004
honestly dario argento made one although
it was what's weird is that they've made
it a romance there's no romance in the
goddamn family operates a serial killer
in the book it's a serial killer like i
said i kind of feel like they did that a
lot they took some like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
from me
they did the same thing with dracula
yeah which like turned into like [ __ ]
twilight yeah
like the romance vampires which are
monsters
and we're gonna like turn it into a
romance even though even in twilight
there's like the dude was a [ __ ]
stalker straight up yeah
and in the book we're gonna make that
seem like it's romantic right [ __ ] that
[ __ ] in the book no way in the book
[ __ ] eric there's no romance involved
he's using [ __ ] psychological warfare
to bring this starlet under his [ __ ]
spell she's totally submissive
approaches her at first yeah because she
thinks he's a ghost
and i'm the angel of music
that her dead father told her would
visit her right he's lying to her who he
is sure and he's speaking to her through
the walls and [ __ ] and he's got all
these damn secret
and then he abducts her yeah and takes
her and her [ __ ] boyfriend tries to
save her he tortures his ass
you just gotta reach and drowns the
brother right yeah yeah he's he's
although like i said his boyfriend's not
super great either no but you know what
i'm saying right and what they're
describing is a serial killer not not
romeo
yeah you know yeah let's not let's not
romanticize that right yeah
he's the worst right he's a terrible
person
like i said he's sympathetic because he
grew up all [ __ ] up right but he's not
a good dude but he's not a good person
no he's not a good person no
like desperate
it's not like beauty and the beast i
kind of feel like this gets compared to
beauty and the beast yeah
beauty and the beast though
is
i mean as far as i remember it's been a
while
beauty and the beast he just looked like
a
like a lion or monster or something yeah
but he wasn't a serial killer no he was
right yeah
right so he's just kind of like well he
was just this dude he looked all [ __ ]
up like a lion or whatever and he just
like lived in his library and then he
like he has finds this beautiful woman
and she's like okay you're kind of like
cranky but you know i i love you
whatever
this dude
is
not a good person no deep down no not a
good person okay
let's shut it off if everybody's leaving
anyway all right okay
lol yeah no romance no there was no
romantic yeah no uh so i think it's kind
of funny they did that but like i said
they did that with dracula too so yeah
i i don't know i i i don't advocate it
i'm just saying it happened it happened
right um i'm not i wasn't a part of a
party to it so uh all right thank you
everybody for dropping by for the show
this was super fun yeah this is a good
topic
um
but yeah all right so we will be back
friday evening to do our side track show
which as you all know is
the no topic whatever you can ask us
whatever show
but thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for super chats and we will see
you guys on friday evening
uh
bye